[Musique]
m bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle Maget Serge Monsieur Philippe
cor
[Musique]
voil PHPP PHPP que vous retrouverez tous
les dimanches soir à la viané à
poré Monsieur
[Musique]
Philippe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Philippe Corti bravo merci voici la
bombe atomique voici Adriana
caramb
[Applaudissements]
bravo et oui Adriana caramb
là je vous demande de vous arrêter je
vous demande de vous arrêter Adriana
carambe la plus belle chose qui nous a
été envoyée par les pays de l'est
vraiment je dois dire vous êtes
magnifique c'est la plus belle chose qui
est venue de l'Est depuis toujours voilà
alors vous êtes de plus en plus Jol en
plus toujours gentil avec moi mais je
suis toujours gentil avec vous et je
vous trouve de plus en plus joli en plus
vraiment gentil
avec alors il y a un problème c'est que
moi quand je travaille chez moi comme ça
j'ai LCI allumé toute la journée sans le
son c'est juste pour avoir l'heure et et
alors toute la journée il y a un spot
qui passe avec Adri caramb et quand on
voit le spot on dit comment il fait pour
bosser en disant merde magn Serge
[Musique]
les gestes qui sauvent avec la Croix
Rouge c'est un mannequin qui vous les
apprendra si Adriana n'est pas là c'est
Robert qui s'en
chargera voilà Adriana
camb dans le spot de la
Croix-Rouge
sensibilisation du grand public ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'en France il y a
seulement 32 % des gens qui sont formés
au premier secours alors qu'en
Angleterre ils sont 44 et en Allemagne
ça'étonnera personne ils ont réformé les
Allemands au premier secours ils sont 80
% à être formés au premier secours nous
on est que voilà alors s'il y avait 20 %
de la population française qui était
formée au premier secours on sauverait
10000 vies par an les premiers secours
oui oui bien sûr on va non mais parce
que les gens qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
petit se passe vous avez bien vu
hein ce qui se passe c'est que les gens
meurent avant l'arrivée des premiers
secours je dis ça en marrant mais bon
c'est vrai que c'est pas rigol et
pourtant ce sont des gestes simples qui
peuvent sauver d'ailleurs Titof oui si
vous vouliez vous allonger
là
ouiis
vous vous allongez là voyez là là là non
non là là là
là et Adriana non là là Adriana va vous
apprendre va nous apprendre à tous les
gestes qui vous avez beaucoup de chance
ti parce que vous avez vu d'habitude
c'est Robert d'habitude c'est Robert
c'est un mannequin je vais te donner un
petit chewing-gum quand
même c'est pour vous pour moi je moi
c'est pour le bouche à
bouche c'est pour le bouche à bouche il
a un petitwingum
je me mets comment en
faitus c'est la plage comme ça oui vous
êtes inconscient ah oui j'ai très
mal all toi tu es blessé ti vous êtes
inconscient ah oui
complètement alors d'abord on regarde on
protège la place on regarde sil y a pas
danger on va s'occuper de de la
victime alors d'abord on va regarder s
respire on va cou la tête en
arrière comm ça on va écouter s'il
respire mais c'est sérieux c'est pour
sauver des vies normalement on regarde
on écoute s respire on regarde si sa
poitrine ça bouge mais il respire très
bien il respire un peu vite même je
pense oui s'il respire bien on va le
mettre position sur la côté position de
séc
c'est comment la position de sécurité je
ne peux pas vous montrer parce que il va
tomber
mais normalement vas-y tu peux tu peux
me c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je m'intéresse au geste qui saut non non
non non mais mets-toi mets-toi sur le
côté Tito faut montrer la position
survie
voilà voilà ah
ouais vous êtes
hor
là
oui non non non tu me sers un T s'il te
plaît le oh
oui j'adore la non non j'arrête j'arrête
j'arrête parce que c'est c'est important
d'avoir c'est important respire pas si
respire pas on fait bouche à bouche et
la massage cardiaque ou massage
cardiaque c'est comment tournez-vous non
mais bouche à bouche aussi mais vous
vous respirez déjà alors on n pas besoin
à faire OK sinon on fait deux fois
bouche à bouche après on trouve le
sternum il est là et
moitié on fait 15 fois ah sur à la
moitié du sternum on fait ça pour faire
redémarrer le cœuris et le cycle on
répète 5 fois par minute après
examination si il respire pas on appelle
samou bien
sûr parce qu'on a besoin je crois que il
faut pas appeler Sam on beso on besoin
on besoin on a besoin de d'aide on a
besoin d'amour on a besoin
d'amour
bravo
bravo on va voir si j'ai tout bien tout
bien compris tu vas t'allonger un peu
sur
alors on va rester dans les gestes qui
sauvent on va vous faire une interview
rose on ne bouge pas pendant le
[Musique]
jingle et voilà tu n'as pas bougé vous
n'avez pas bougé P le jingle n pas bougé
non plus et Adriana n'a pas bougé non
plus bravo
[Applaudissements]
ti ah vous avez une
F c'est la première fois que j'arrive à
faire réussir un truc aussi dur vraiment
c'est bien vous avez répété bien alors
l'interview alerte rose si vous
comprenez en français vous répondez en
français sinon vous répondez en anglais
elle notre ami traductrice qui est là je
crois bien sûr bien s tu es là toujours
tout à fait ou je te vois tu es prêt tu
t'appelles comment Belinda oh Belinda
une chanson cl de franis Belinda bien
alors quelle est la première pensée que
vous avez Adriana caramb quand vous
trouve en face d'un homme
séduisant que je
pense maintenant je ne pense plus à rien
à l'époque dans le temps Adri je dis
tout de suite c'est pas l'interview
mensonge vous pouvez répondre la
vérité quel est pour vous Adriana le
lieu idéal pour une
étreinte
best place best place partout
[Applaudissements]
partout si c'est la bonne personne tous
les lieux bonne réponse bonne réponse si
c'est la bonne personne tous les lieux
sont bons c'est parfait quel est
l'endroit Adri carambù vous êtes
incapable de faire
l'amourace je pense pas que j'aimerais
être dans l'espace à cause de la
pesanteur ça me fait peur ouais ouais ah
oui ça faire l'amour dans la ça doit
être difficile déjà faut se trouverà
avec les
tenu déjà pour s'embrasser avec
le vous préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer prer oh je préfère franchement
qu' drague bon on se renseigne nous hein
vous préférez vous faire vous préférez
larguer les mecs ou vous faire
larguer
oh ben évidemment je préfère être celle
qui
part c'est beaucoup plus gratifiant si
que ça va
Belinda ça pour ah Belinda tentends
Belinda là j'entends bien elle est bien
Belinda bien vous préférez embrasser ou
vous faire embrasser i prer to kiss je
préfère embrasser caresser ou vous faire
caresser bah le deux les deux oh là là
coquine ou Catherine me dit en régie que
vous arrêtez pas de regarder C simpin
pourquoi c'est pas vrai non non
non non non non non non je réclamation
non non c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai et
vous allez voir si on peut si on remet
le Magnetto au c le micro était était
tombé le micro le petit micro donc j'ai
regardé j'ai dit tiens il s'est remis en
place et si on refait un si on fait un
ralentistion on revient en arrière vous
verrez que le le micro d'Adriana était
tombé comme ça je disais mais on va pas
l'entendre je mais qu pour l'émission
moi Adriana caramb j'avais même pas
remarqué
euh non non est-ce que vous conservez tu
travaille dans la
mode Adriana est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous conserz un fantasme
inavouable vas-y Belinda tradu ça oh
j'en ai beaucoup des fantasmes ah ouais
il y en a il y a encore des fantamesavez
pas réalisé il sont encore dans votre
tête seulement oui
oui je dire unuc je veux dire il
monsieur guirou qui
est je le vois faire ah oui oui
oui il y a guirou il y a guirou qui dit
pourquoi je rentre pas sur le plateau
attends gu attends 5 minutes bien alors
maintenant voilà des gens qui' qui
m'envoient des questions comme ça par
email un dénommé trist en poirier alors
il me dit vous demandez si vous préférez
demandez aux gens si fille si elle
préfère un homme infidèle qui fait bien
l'amour ou infidèle qui fait mal l'amour
alors il me dit au Moyen-Âge comme quoi
c'est vraiment une émission culturelle
c'est incroyable au Moyen-Âge il y avait
les poètes les poètes du Moyen-âge ils
jouaient à des débats amoureux qui
s'appelaient les jeux parties
et alors ils avaient des questions comme
ça finalement on a rien inventé au Moyen
Âge jou déjà à ça par exemple je posais
c'est vraiment une question du Moyen-Âge
ça c'est c'est historique he c'est trist
en poirier il habite dans le 16e est
très sérieux et tout alors est-ce que
vous préférez posséder si vous deviez
posséder la moitié d'un homme vous
préféreriez avoir le haut ou le
bas difficile he difficile mais c'est un
truc voil de top de top je pense que
c'est le haut ah ouais non parce que là
il y avait une ou alors tu passais pour
quelqu'un de romantique ou tu passais
pour une super chaude en fait elle passe
pas elle préfère elle préfère passer
pour quelqu'un de romantique quelqu'un
de romantique vous pouvez penser comme
ça je préfèreur alors attention celle-là
est compliquée hein question du
Moyen-Âge hein euh faut-il mieux croire
que votre mec vous trompe sans être sûr
ou être sûr qu'il vous a trompé mais le
fera plus est-ce qu'il vaut mieux croire
que votre mec vous trompe sans être sûr
ou être sûr qu'il vous a trompé mais
qu'il le fera plus là Belinda elle rame
je suis sûr tu rames
Belinda je ne peux pas que
je pas je pourrais vivre sans
savoir vous préférez
quoi ah Christian a une autre femme dans
sa vie Christian ah bon il a une autre
femme dans sa vie c'est un jeu c'est un
jeu il a une autre femme dans sa vie il
vous reçoit les deux le même soir vous
et son autre et sa maîtresse il vous
reçoit les deux le même soir c'est
je est-ce qu'il vaut mieux arriver deè
lorsque l'autre femme sort satisfaite ou
sortir satisfaite quand l'autre
arrive je prère priè vous préférez
sortir satisfaite quand l'autre arrive
d'accord d'acord
d'cord je ce que je veux puis après je
m'en moque d'accord moi par
[Musique]
contre
moi si j'étais Christian peut-être il
pourrait les faire venir aussi les deux
en même temps c'est ce que je ferais si
j'étais Christian mais bon c'est pas au
moyen âge si on était au Moyen Âge truc
de moyenge Moyen ge et voilà Adriana 42
l'interview alerte
rose bien j'accueille maintenant sans
plus
attendre
voici Christian
[Musique]
carambe Christian carambe mesdames
messieurs bonsoir alors Christian on a
beaucoup d'admiration pour vous hein
pourquoi admire beaucoup pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que vous faites
partie des Bleus donc vous êtes une star
et deuxièmement parce que vous êtes le
mari d'Adriana carambe qu'on a tous
admiré ici de nombreuses fois et qu'on
est prêt à admirer encore très souvent
je te le dis Adriana bien alors
Christian donc vous êtes Canac oui
carambu ça veut dire l'homme en colère
c'est ça non dites-moi si je me trompe
ouais c'est ça ça veut dire un carambe
c'est quelqu'un c'est un statut guerrier
quoi c'est quelqu'un c'est très guerrier
de toute façon enfin je crois que dans
la nuit des temps dans tout les peuples
du monde ont ont donné des des ns par
rapport à la nature aux arbres et ce aux
pierres et Cera ouais c'est un guerrier
un carambe alors vous êtes né en 1970 à
l'ifou près d'ouva en Nouvelle-Calédonie
donc qu'on appellera la kanakie bientôt
ça va être indépendant la Nouvelle
Calédonie non c'est en instance oui
d'indépendance alors il y a une histoire
terrible dans votre famille qui a été
révélé par Didier des Ninx dans un livre
s'appelle les cannibales c'est que les
ancêtres de Christian carambeu ont été
emmenés en en métropole comme on disait
à l'époque pour être exhibé à la foire à
l'exposition coloniale de 1931 c'est une
histoire absolument terrible donc on les
a mis nu dans une case espèce de de
réplique grotesque d'une vraie case
canque on les a mis dans des costumes
exotiques on les a obligé à manger de la
viande crue et on les présentait comme
des cannibales polygames c'était un
petit peu l'attraction comme ça de de de
cette foire exposition d'attraction
vedette et ensuite ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'ils ont été échangés avec un
zoau le zoo de Hambourg contre des
crocodiles c'est qu'après ils sont
partis au zoau de Hambourg j'ai vu le
reportage ouais terrible cette histoire
c'est terrifiant vous saviez pas vous
hein c'était on n parlait pas de ça chez
vous non on n parlait pas parce que
c'était honteux de d'en parler ouais
cela dit j'en j'en ai moi j'en ai
profité pardelà mon statut de pouvoir
sensibiliser les gens d'abord sur mon
pays sur mon peuple et bien sûr par les
des miens oui ouais alors ceci étant
quand quand il y a eu le massacre
d'ouva euh des canaes ont été achevés
des Canaques qui se rendaient les mains
en l'air ont été achevé par par des gens
qui portaient l'uniforme de la
République c'est un peu la même chose
d'une certaine façon et c'est pas si
vieux non c'est jamais vieux enfin je
crois que il faut toujours mettre chaque
situation dans son contexte
euh l'époque des mien
c'était justement le pouvoir colonial
qui existait qui existe toujours
d'ailleurs et par de par ce fait la
France a voulu démontrer justement
l'étendue de son pouvoir quand vous
étiez petit on vous a appris nos ancêit
les Gaulois exactement oui ça
terrible bien en fait quand vous étiez
petit vous étiez plus intéressé par le
foot et les footballeurs que par l'école
et vous connaissiez les les joueurs de
football par la télé bien sûr mais aussi
par les magazines par des magazines
comme France Football comme 11 he vous
étiez repéré par un ancien footballeur
professionnel s'appelle Marc cagnant euh
qui a dit il faut l'envoyer en métropole
pour pour le former alors votre mère euh
hésitait un peu ouais vouliz être
médecin vous demandiez c'était pas mieux
de rester là-bas et d'être médecin et
finalement vous êtes parti au centre de
formation de de Nantes le départ ça dû
être terrible avec tout le monde qui ben
c'est toujours difficile de de se
séparer du du cquan familial surtout
dans ma culture où on est très c'est la
tribu voilà exactement on est nombreux
en plus ouais et mais je crois qu'il y
avait j'avais envie de de de casser un
peu cette euh cette osmose mais en même
temps grandir surtout voil quand vous
montez dans l'avion bon vous êtes un peu
triste un peu comme ça les larmes aux
yeux puis quand les portes se referment
vous dites voilà il faut que j'ai
simplement essué mes larmes en me disant
voilà il faut que je revienne avec au
moins une quelque chose non bravo c'est
réussi alors quand vous arrivez quand
vous arrivez en métropole alors
évidemment vous avez des c'est le mois
d'octobre il fait froid vous avez des
sandal vous êtes pas du tout habillé
pour la saison et en décembre un jour
vous habitiez près de la gare un jour
vous vous regardez par la fenêtre et
tout est blanc vous descendez en calçon
dans dans la rue vous faites un tour
pied nu dans la neige que vous aviez
jamais vu de neige donc c'était quelque
chose pour vous c'est étonnant bah c'est
c'est merveilleux de pouvoir rencontrer
quelque chose qu'on ne connaît pas
encore une fois très ouvert à la
découverte en fait parce
[Musique]
que ma philosophie est justement de
toujours connaître autant demande mais
en M S les découvrir mais avec
émerveillement et je suis toujours
surpris agréblement surpris de connaître
ce que je connais pas voilà alors vous
imaginez en plus que la métropole c'est
des gratciel c'est des des des trucs
ultra modernes et en fait vous êtes très
impressionné à NAND parce que c'est
c'est des vieilles maisons et vous dit
toujours j'ai l'impression que je vais
croiser d'Artagnan quoi parce que tout
ça est assez assez antique ex maisant on
peut renconter des pavés d'ailleurs il y
a encore la le château de la duessan qui
existe
encore les promenades de la Loire où les
châteauxement existent autour de la
Loire de l'Erdre aussi donc là ça m'a
permis de revenir en arrière de pouvoir
côtoyer pas côtoyer mais au moins
revivre des imag de KDP et j'ai pensé à
d'Artagnan les trquair voilà voilà bon
après il y a toute l'histoire l'équipe
de France vous AZ jamais été victime de
racisme en France non heureusement non
non non mais même mes oreilles se
ferment quand ouais voulez pasentendre
tout aussi bien non parce que je crois
que le silence est une meilleure réponse
à ouais comme le proverbe si ce que tu
as dire est moins beau que le silence
alors tu es
toi pensez pas pensez pas que les mecs
qui si on a répété tout à l'heure pensez
pas que les mecs qui silent ils sont
jaloux parce que vous êtes avec Adriana
ah je sais pas ah mais si mais je crois
que c'est ça comment ça va avec elle
alors très bien parce que bon est
elle est dans les dans les loges
non la presse scandale annonce
régulièrement votre séparation mais tout
va bien tout va très bien oui tout va
très bien très bien on va voir comment
ça s'est passé Serge 2è compte de
celui-à tout le monde le connaît hein
dans un bus
d'aéroport super connu vous connaissez
dans un bus d'aéroport non non je
connais pas vous connaissez pas bah elle
tombe sur un un type qui lui dit
vachement intelligent la question vous
mesurez combien déjà voilà comment
draguer Adriana 4 si tu veux et ben vous
vous saviez même pas qui il était en
plus vous saviez pas que c'était un un
grand grand joueur de foot lui il
pensait j'ai aucune chance il s'est dit
tu vois évidemment j'ai aucune chance
tout le monde pense ça en vous voyant et
vous vous vous dit et vous vous dites
quand les hommes me voient ils pensent
toujours j'ai aucune chance et voilà ça
marchera jamais alors que c'est pas vrai
ils sont con ces mecs aussi là comme les
autres dire bien sûr ouais faut
arrêter prie mais bien sûr non mais mais
mais son son mari est trè très beau he
c'est un très bel homme oui Non Non mais
il faut le dire parce que je dis bon
tous les deux alors c'est
ouais le couple étincelant parce qu'on
on ne regarde plus personne d'autre mais
je veux dire quand ils arrivent mais lui
il sait vraiment un très bel homme donc
il est dit j'ai pas ma chance moi j'y
crois pas trop hein parce que sait quand
même que dites-moi José mauais si vous
si vous rencontriez Adrien carambe dans
un bus d'aéroport vous lui diriez quoi
pour pour la branché est-ce que vous lui
diriez comme Christian je mesure 1
M22 vous diriez quoi José sérieux ah
vous me vous me ah il faut que je dise
pareil en fait hein oui combien vous
mesurez vous mesurez combien ouais ah
maintenant c'est trop tard trop tard
trop tard trouver autre chose voilà et
donc alors après bon il montte dans
l'avion tous les deux vous d'habitude
faites semblant de dormir quand vous
êtes dans un avion là vous gardez un œil
un œil ouvert il se met à côté d'elle et
puis voilà puis à la fin du voyage il
vous a laissé son chapeau ça c'est un
truc à savoir avec Adriana carambe il
faut laisser son chapeau parelle a
beaucoup ça vous a touché oui parce que
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est-ce
que je vais faire avec mon chapeau
c'était un peu
ouais B c'était mignon parce qu'elle me
disait j'ai rien j'ai rien sur moi elle
avait pas même pas même pas le valise
rien alors il m'a donné cas voilà et
alors vous lui donnez votre numéro de
téléphone quand même assez rapidement
hein la première fois vous avez donné
votre c'est vrai normalement je fais pas
ça bah oui j'espère bien et alors de
jours plus tard il vous appelle et vous
l'inviter à prendre un café mais comme
vous êtes à milans et lui à Paris le mec
il prend un avion là c'est déjà plus
voilà c'est déjà plus fort là il dit à
Milan t'en fais pas j'arrive voilà ça
c'est fort il a gagné et un an après
dans un restaurant fin du deième compte
de fée un an après dans le restaurant il
prend votre main comme ça sous la table
il enlève votre vieille bague et il se
casse par une bague de
C voilà comment vous vous êtes fait
voler la bague de votre maman et de
votre papa non il lui dit veux-tu être
ma femme tu voas le mec que trucs simple
combien vous mesurez est-ce que tu veux
être ma femme tu veux mon chapeau tu
veux mon chapeau nous on se fatigue àer
des trucs genre je fais de la télé tous
les samedis pas du
tout s'en fout vous fondz en L voilà fin
du deuxème compte de voilà et voilà et
voilà
bravo bravo alors vous dites au départ
j'étais pas séduit par la plastique
d'Adriana mais fasciné parce qu'elle est
dans son âme oui
oui parce que nous pauvre con qu'on est
on aurait été quand même fasciné d'abord
par sa plastique non non parce que
revenait je crois qu'elle venait de
finir un un clip ou un travail en fait
donc il était ni bien maquillé ni ouis
oui donc les cheveux un peu é bourifés
ouais sa pressence son allure qui m'a
plus et après quand j'ai pu lui parler
voilà ouais mais vous dites après le vol
M en Paris j'étais incapable de la
décrire physiquement donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui s'est passé au niveau
du regard effectivement ouaisoui oui du
regard du dialogue oui ouais alors vous
dites je suis tellement conscient de
l'aimer que je ressens pas le besoin de
multiplier les démonstrations d'amour ce
qu'elle me reproche parfois lorsque je
rentre exténué et que je m'affale devant
la télé Christian merde Christian merde
non parce que en
fait ça c'est son c'est des c'est un
petit détail ouais mais je crois que un
sentiment on le donne avec intégrité on
le donne pas pour jouer ou je sais pas
bien alors Adriana était là en novembre
on lui a fait l'interview alerte rose et
alors aujourd'hui on va vous poser les
mêmes questions pour savoir si vous
répondez
pareil je crois on ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle on bouge pas pendant le
[Applaudissements]
jingle quelle est votre première pensée
lorsque vous vous retrouvez face à une
femme séduisante femme séduisante elle
est séduisante ouais ouais si elle est
séduisante séduisante qu'elle répond
elle quand même Adriana ah je sais pas
dit depuis que j'ai rencontré Christian
je ne pense plus à rien lorsque je me
trouve en face d'un homme
séduisant vous y croyez
pas je n'en sais trop rien alors bon va
qu'on continue le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte pour vous vraiment caché loin
de tout le monde ouais ouais elle répond
pas ça ah elle dit le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte c'est partout si je suis
avec la bonne personne non mais c'est
intéressant de voir parce que bon il y a
peut-être une ouverture
hein l'endroit Christian l'endroit où
vous seriez incapable de faire
l'amour
en parce que vous vous pensez l'amour
c'est simplement faire le coï mais moi
l'amour c'est aussi dans le regard donc
je peux faire partout oui c'est vrai
nous on est un peu physique on est non
je va vous dire
e les Français on est comme des sauvages
nous non elle elle a répondu dans
l'espace elle a dit dans l'espace je
pourrais pas faire l'amour dans l'espace
parce que j'aurais peur ah je dis peur
des avions ou alors est-ce que vous
préférez draguer ou vous faire
draguer les deux les deux elle c'est se
faire draguer est-ce que vous préférez
larguer ou vous faire
larguer mais faire larguer moi j'ai rien
à oua là vous êtes d'accord elle dit je
préfère être celle qui largue celle qui
pass est-ce que vous préférez embrasser
ou vous faire embrasser
embrasser
elle aussi est-ce que vous préférez
caresser ou vous faire
caresser j'aime bien les elle aussi
est-ce qu'il y a encore des fantasmes
que vous n'avez pas
réalisé si j'en ai oui j'en ai pas
réalisé non oui elle dit oui beaucoup
donc faut vous y coler quand même
arrê il faut arrêter de reg je vous dis
ce qu'elle répond il faut arrêter de
regarder la télé si vous deviez choisir
la moitié d'une femme vous prendriez le
haut ou le bas la moitié d'une femme
ouais vous prendriez le haut ou le bas
en S la coupé en deux ah ou c'est vous
c'est autre chose Joh en
travers le haut ou le
bas mais la femme n'existe pas en une
moitié c'est ça que je vrais qu'estce
qui m'arve voilà Christian 42 amoureux
de sa femme
JIS
ma magnet
Serge faut qu'on inverse les rô c'est le
gage que j'avais acceptéé allez
bien on ne bouge pas pendant le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jingle ah c'estosant de faire ma F
c'estosant mais là où tu es très con
c'est que je vais te virer pour la
prochaine
émission dit bonsoir vous avez 20 ans
vous avez déjà fait 20 films X
professionnels 22 22 22 ah ouais c'est
encore mieux et vous avez aussi un duc
de de philo vous l'avez eu à l'âge de 18
ans c'est pour ça qu'on vous appelle 19
19 19 mal avec les chiffres ouais et
vous avez fait un 68
69 bien alors à 13 ans vous décidez de
plus manger de viande oui vous devenez
vétalienne ce qui n'est pas végétarienne
moi j'ai vu un film manger de la
viande alors maintenant on accueille la
vie est
F libre volage la vie s quand on la met
en
[Applaudissements]
al lu promet d'être belle car VO qu'
fond du cielî la
let au
louanges chassé par
leses
qui
est ce qui est
[Applaudissements]
fa conis
système
[Applaudissements]
qu'il
fait
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va Jacques et ben vraiment
très très
bien c'est génial vous connaissez l Moon
ah
justement une anecdote
racontez-moi ça et bien nous passions
dans la rue avec ma fille oui par hasard
une rue qui descend et qui passe devant
le Palais des Glaces justement et alors
on voulait aller ailleurs mais tout
était fermé ce soir-là et vous jouez
exact j'étais comédien à
l'époque et vous êtes venu voir le
spectacle j'ai dit à ma fille est-ce que
ça t'intéresse de voir quelqu'un qui
fait rire les autres elle m'a dit tout à
fait parce que c'est un enfant qui a
beaucoup d'humour et alors on a garé la
voiture on est revenu on a demandé s'il
y avait des places on a payé alors je
vous don
combien et après on est rentré dans le
théâtre c'était la première fois qu'on
allait dans un théâtre aussi tous les
deux et elle était très fière elle m'a
pris par le bras vous permettez c'est
une
reconstitution que toi et elle m'a pris
par le bras elle était très fière elle a
regardé si tout le monde la voyait et
elle s'est penché sur moi et on a
attendu que le rideau s'ouvre et quand
le rideau s'est ouvert elle s'est serré
contre moi avec
ça va pour la reconstitution je sais pas
après ce que vous avez fait mais donc ça
lui a plu à votre fille très bien ou oui
mais j'avais appris que vous vous étiez
venus en faitou m'en est pas venu après
parce que je sais que quand les artistes
ont terminé ils ont envie d'être vous
avez besoin de VOUS éponger ça m'aurait
fait plaisir de vous voir vous avez
déclaré à 50 ans on commence à descendre
quand vous aviez 50 ans maintenant vous
en avez 60 vous pensez quoi euh sex ça
génère ouais ça dit ce que ça dit ouais
sex AG génère ah sex génère oui
oui
donc ça va quoi c'est insensé parce que
en fait c'est 50 ans qui est dur après
on remonte aprs ah bon c'est sympa ah
bon d'accord c'est parce que c'est
demisiècle quand on vous rappelle que
vous avez dit à 50 ans on commence à
descendre vous dites oui mais la
descente est belle vous avez cette
phrase formidable avant on était jeune
et beau maintenant on est beau bon fait
un peu de promo mot allez allez si vous
voulez
Mar non
mais lui il fait ça que quand c'est sa
cassette mais ça va pas non ouis c'est
pas
vrai il faut le faire pour tout le monde
non non mais attends c'est faux j'adore
ce qu'il fait donc c'est absolument pas
quoi commencer à faire un scandale c'est
ça à faire les conneries maintenant moi
non c'est simplement qu'on sent on sent
un peu con ah je sais bah oui je sais
bien c'est pour ça et tu préfères vas-y
et tu veux que ma femme et moi on passe
pour des con on le
fait ça ça va mieux ouais Mareva
oui et ben dis non
ouis bien alors le nouvel album de
Jacquy Gelin c'est live 2000 donc c'est
euh chez Warner dans un label qui
s'appelle tôt ou tard il y a 10 titres
parmi les les les meilleurs moments de
la dernière tournée siouz nous en dire
un mot
Mau vous permettez ouais ma ouais parce
que
ouais bien alors ma donc vous allez nous
parler de cet album là zoom zoom mon
garçon zoom zoom zoom
zo c'est lui qui a fait la la pochette
ah c'est pas mal la pochette poette la
pochette zoom rezoom rezoom voilà
bien bonsoir
Monsieur bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir
Mara bonsoir Monsieur bonsoir Ellie
bonsoir Monsieur bonsoir
bonsoirons ça va faire bizarre c'est
voilà donc vous avez collaboré avec
Jackie Gelin sur son dernier album qui
s'appelle live 2000
oui tu peux parler là par le micro
fonctionne
oui TIF est
tendu c'estàdire que E JAC vous devez
pas vous faire chier avec lui en
tourné oh non avec lui je m'éclate
ça il sont
malad c'était ma
onalaudit
alors il est génial ton copain qu'est-ce
qu'il fait avec vousc fait quoi est
peintre ah il est peintre et je joue
toutes les tournées on l'a fait à deux
et Mau il a tout un jeu de percussion
énorme quoi avec des timbales des des
tambours des cmbales des gongs des femes
sa n'importe quoi n'importe quoi il joue
tout il tape sur tout bien alors bon je
vais faire la promo à la place d'Elin
donc tu zoomes et je dis donc il y a
dans cet album vagalame la vie est folle
chambre sous lestoit Paris New York
tranche de vie Monalisa cllaxon iradier
champagne l'accordé on daccordé et ce
qui est dit doit être fait voilà ver
solitaire ou pas ouis ah j'adore cette
chanson le ver solitaire ver solitaire
ou je suis un genre de ver solitaire de
loup
solitaire attendez
attendez AR arrêtez
minutes non non je dis ça parce que
quand quand j'étais quand j'étais au
collège a 60 ans à peu
près on était très fan de vous
évidemment comme des gens de ma
génération il y avait la chanson le loup
solitaire on av on avait transformé les
paroles pour les les colos ça s'appelait
je suis un genre de solitaire à peine
plus gros qu'une hpè et quand je mais je
me rappelle plus des paroles mais
c'était c'était une espèce de j'ai peur
de vous
maintenant faittion avec ta fille ta
fille vous
comprz dis bonjour
bonjour Lele qu est mon grand
frère non non vous avez compris ce que
je voulais dire
incroyable pas compris he impériale
cette femme vous êtes impériale madame
on peut avoir un plan sur cette femme
qui est
[Applaudissements]
impériale de ver solitaire appelle plus
gros qu'un peur et quand je il essaie de
souvenir des par il ESS
de oui le loup solitaire n c'était le
verre solitaire on était des gamins on
était jeunes on avait à peine voilà à
propos de ver solitaire est-ce que je
pourrais en avoir un qui soit plein oh
joli
ouais
bien on y arrivera on y arrive ça
prendra le temps qu'il faudra on
arrivera au bout de l'émission ouais bon
alors on va parler un peu de
[Applaudissements]
votre
[Musique]
ça allait pas bien cette époque Jacques
là c'est toi là
alorsck l'autre côté de la barrière pour
comprendre votre pour comprendre votre
personnage un peu étudier votre personne
vous êtes n truc l'autre du
toutardé une émission je me trompe quand
c'était Roan fol vous faz une émission
de flic ouais c'était descendre de pop
non pendant à l'époque de votre
naissance et de votre prime enfance
c'était la guerre ouais voilà votre père
était prisonné de guerre un peu mais pas
trop non plus un peu ah oui et vous vous
aviez peur des bombardements de de
cetteous voilà et c'est pour ça que vous
avez gardé cette détestation de la
guerre de la violence et du militarisme
voilà donc déjà quand on sait bien sûr
on dit des fois il arrête pas ilelin
avec la guerre la l'antimilitarisme et
tout c'est normal vous avez été élevé
làedans non non c'est simplement parce
que même même si j'étais pas né
là-dedans quoi parce qu'après quand
j'étais jeune homme il y a eu la guerre
d'Algérie aussi bah oui donc ça faisait
deux fois quoi que j'étais en contact
avec ça mais il y a quand même beaucoup
de monde qui est en contact avec ça sur
la planète quoi je trouve simplement
désarmer tout le monde ce serait enfin
retirer les armes ce serait déjà pas mal
quoi se battre à main nu c'est quand
même plus non pour quoi tu me
regarde faire des duels oui ouais ouai
ouais pas des massacres quoi tu vois
parce que la guerre ça ça laisse des
mauvaises des traces évitez de de faire
attaquer des Noirs par des bergers
allemands par exemple ah la vache entre
autres vous venez en plus ja d'une
famille rebelle parce que dans votre
famille votre grand-père pour échapper
au travail dans les filature ce qui est
un travail très astraignant il est
devenu traducteur d'un fakir oui
trapouzi s'appelait le faakir ah bon
ouais et alors votre père aussi votre
père éit cheminau mais il était aussi
artiste votre père il adorait le piano
il adorait le piano il adorait Charles
traet Maurice Chevalier ouais et tout il
aimait pas Piaf il se trouvait que Piaf
chantait comme une chèvre
ouis ouais mais ça il il avait il avait
peur du noir en plus parce qu'elle était
habillée en noir elle me disait toujours
elle est sinistre c'était vraiment une
autre époqueouis mais il aimait bien il
aimait bien traîner chevalier ce qui
fait que vous avez commencé votre
carrière en fait en chantant du traîner
et du chevalier trac dans les cinémas
accompagné par mon père en Bonlieu en
Bonlieu ta mère j'ai commencé et dans
les radios crochet aussi ouais devant la
gare de
ch et alors vous étiez un enfant assez
spécial quand même hein pourquoi estce
que vous étiez solitaire passiez votre
temps à faire l'école
buissonnière vouliez faire de la la vous
étiez pas faignant en même temps vouliez
faire de la musique du théâtre la
littérature donc vous aviez envie de
vous exprimer mais l'école c'était pas
votre truc alors votre mère était
complice pour vous faire des faux
certificats médicaux
ouais comment il sait ça lui où il va où
il va chercher les les renseignements et
tout chez moi parce que j'ai tous les
renseignements sur tout le monde non
mais c'est vrai vous étiez très
solitaire étranger aux autres c'est
comme ça don j'essaie de savoir comment
devient Jacy Gelin en fait en le restant
oui bonne réponse bah oui ne bois pas
dans mon verre je voulais comprendre un
truc c'est tout c'est de l'essence
d'accord la forme du Gelin c'est qu'il
boit du super en non non mais je bois
jamais ça en plus j'ai bu là parce que
j'avais le trque nonou j'avais peur j'ai
peur de la télére S Jacky jelin vous
quittez l'école à 14 ans j'ai peur vous
avez vous avez fait une comédie musicale
avec cé béchette oui qui
s'appelait nouvelorléand bonne R
alors c'est un concours ou ok
nouvorléand Peter sister d'accord
alorsand quand vous après vous faites un
film et vous rencontrez un guitariste
d'origine gitane qui a composé pour
monan et Piaf et qui vous apprend la
guitare son nom Henri CRA bravo bonne
réponse
ensuite donc voilà c'est vrai qu'avoir
hen comme professeur de guitare c'est
pas mal
pardon on continue la vie de Jacquy
Gelin donc après au début des années 70
c'est long encore non ah bah il a 60 ans
le
me le mec il a 60 ans va pas RER ça en 2
minutes non
plus je ne pense pas donc non mais ça
vous intéresse pas que je vous raconte
votre vie vous la connaissez vous je dis
tout ça parce qu'il y a une scène dans
votre vie que moi je trouve formidable
c'est donc vous êtes un peu faut dire un
peu Hipi un peu Baba à l'époque un un et
tout et un jour pas honte de ça je trais
entendu il personne do avoir honte de ça
et puis un jour vous allez avec votre
costume blanc et votre accordéon faire
la première partie
de et donc Jackie Gelin fait la première
partie de slly et Family Stone avec son
costume blanc son accordon il sent un
peu ridicule bien sûr et vous êtes un
peu jeté par le public oui oui ils m'ont
jeté ils m'ont dit casse-toi vire-toi de
là et j'ai commencé à l'accordéon
j'étais habillé tout en blanc devant une
salle qui était venue pour voir SL
family Storm et j'ai commencé à jouer et
ça est devenu très houleux j'ai eu
l'impression moi d'être au milieu de la
tempête avec un mec sur un épave avec un
accordéon en train de chanter dans la la
dans l'ouragan et puis à un moment donné
ils se sont calmés parce que j'ai
continué ouais et quand ils sont arrêtés
j'étais épuisé j'ai posé l'accordéon et
je leur ai dit je m'en vais mais je
reviendrai et je reviendrai pas tout
seul et là je suis sorti de ce concert
je chialais dans les escalier là par où
toutes les danseuses tous les musiciens
arrivaient en marchant dessus en plus et
là j'ai étis j'avais pas beaucoup de
Rong j'étais acheté un blouson à à
saint-toin au de puce et votre
camionnette était en panne en plus ouais
et j'ai marché avec un jean et tout et
dit maintenant c'est la guerre je vais
faire du rock et je vais rentrer dedans
parce que je vois
que c'est la guerre quoi et bien décidé
et là j'ai démarré le truc à fond la
caisse est-ce que ma guitare est un
fusil Paris New York et tout est-ce que
tous ces engagements et cette carte Ière
très très longue est-ce que finalement
ça vous a pas empêché un petit peu de
vous occuper de vos enfants ah pas du
tout que votre fils alors quand je lui
parle Arthur hche je lui demande si'il
s'entendait bien avec vous et il dit je
m'entendais d'autant mieux avec lui
qu'il était jamais là à une époque
c'était comme ça mais c'est plus comme
ça et vont s'exliquer et on s'entend
très bien ça va maintenant oui c'est une
époque où jeouais mais c'est une autre
histoire ça a rien à voir avec Arthur
c'est ce que je lui ai dit que moi j'en
souffrais autant que lui mais il y a des
moments où c'est des histoires de
d'amour de femme de voilà qui fait qu'on
quitte une femme pour une autre et alors
c'était autre chose quoi mais c'est
pas j'en ai souffert aussi et je lui dis
un jour on a pleuré tous les deux et je
lu dit moi aussi ça m'a manqué
terriblement quoi mais bon c'est des
choses privées aussi il a beaucoup de
talent votre fils ouioup et j'aime
vraiment ce qu'il fait moi Arthur
beaucoup et même pendant un temps il
voulait pas s'appelelin parce qu'il
était sûr que les médias allaient dire
il a la copie de son père ou c'est son
père qui l'aide mais c'est pas moi qui a
aidé Arthur c'est sa mère qui l'a
vraiment aidé ouais et et Arthur il
s'est aidé lui-même parce que moi je
l'ai vu faire c'est un mec qui s'est
créé lui-même quoi et j'ai du respect de
ça je l'ai pas j'ai pas comment tu dis
les les il marche ce [__] de micro
mais o il marchez redonner un petit peu
de gazoelle là
pour bien alors comme vous êtes
quelqu'un de sincère Jacquy Gelin et
vous venez de le prouver en disant ce
que vous venez de dire au sujet de
d'Arthur hash on va vous faire une
interview mensonge on ne bouge pas
pendant le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jingle bravo
ouais bravo pourquoi bravo parce que tu
parce que vous n'avez pas bougé pendant
le jingle mais j'ai bougé les yeux
normalement on doit même pas cligner des
yeux pendant le jingle ah non mais moi
j'ai bougé les yeux en rythme de haut en
bas de gauche à droite tout le temps
mais je vous ai pas vu ben voilà c'est
ça la force de la révolte
des rebelles c'est pas de faire
prendre super flic il m'a pas vu quoi on
va vous faire une interview mensonge
rire ouais vous allez mentir ah il faut
que je mente oui pourquoi bah parce que
c'est une interview mensonge ah bon ça
va être dur pour vous non bien on va
voir B je sais pas j'ai déjà menti aussi
c'est vrai que vous avez une fortune en
fait et que vous avez beaucoup de
beaucoup d'argent qui est placé en
action sur le marché international alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire est-ce que tu
as des dis-moi dis-nous la vérité déjà
on te dira si attendsend reprend vous
êtes bourré de blé ah
ouais il comm il commence à
comprendre est-ce que est-ce que vous
baladez toujours en limousine vitre
fumée vous faites allumer vos clubes par
vos assistants ah ouais ah oui ah bah ça
évidemment
ouais est ça commence à rentrer
[Applaudissements]
là c'est dur avec lui hein e il quand on
fait ça aux hommes politiques il y a pas
de problème les mec sans souci
comprennent tout de suite mais dès qu'on
fait ça avec un artiste c'est plus
compliqué oui vous êtes toujours inscrit
à l'UDF c'est quoi
l'UDF l'Union l'Union des des mental des
fromagés évidemment ouais bien sûr UDF
mais c'est vrai Jackie Gelin vous avez
été obligé d'arrêter de fumer des
pétards pour pouvoir vous inscrire à
l'UDF arrêter de fumer des pétards pour
attend parce que je fume des pétards
alors arrêtez attends il y a deux
mensonges faire un truc
contradictoire arrêtez de fumer des P 60
ans he quand
même tu fais oui tu dis oui j'ai arrêté
de fumer des pétard veux dire que non tu
as pas arrêté de fumer des pétards ah
oui c'est ça oui j'ai arrêté de F queudf
en fume et qu' l'UDF ils en fument c'est
ça que ça ve etudf il fument des pét ils
en fument plein plein voilà sur le plan
sexuel vous sautez toujours sur tout ce
qui
bouge non oui oui dis
dis non faut dire non vérit ça vudra
dire que tu sautes sur tout ce qui bouge
avec les gens qui fument des
pard cétait
LEF je sais ce que je dis arrê de fumer
des pétards pour rentrer à
l'EDF on Esser va essayer une autre
question on Esser unere question vous
êtes quand vous faites vos tournées en
province vous fréquentez toujours
beaucoup les boîtes
échangistes
oui et là tu me regardes pas quand tu
dis ça parce que je ve pas te à
ça non mais attends c'est quoi le plan
là parce que qu'est-ce qu'il y a cette
histoire là cet été à Saint tropé avec
la porn
star ah là tu dis non là tu dis non
pourquoi comme ça les gens vont croire
trop compliquéop compliqué oui à la porn
star non
oui non parce qu'on l' quand même
retrouvé morte dans une pinade à côté de
Saint- tropé la fille
comment il est malin c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un non mais c'est vrai un
manipulateur né on l'a retrouvé morte
dans une pinade à côté de Saint- tropé
pined ouais star du
P bon dernière question jaciein très
très compliqué l'interview mensongeement
les hommes politiques ça passe tout seul
euh vous avez déclaré j'aimerais mourir
comme Elvis prley c'est-à-dire intoxiqué
au médicament au sucreries c'est vrai
ça c'est dur de oui oui oui parce que
dans le jeu oui oui j'ai rêvé ça oui bon
oui alors le résultat de ça c'est quoi
ben si vous arrivez pas à mentir c'est
un test c'est un test vous n'arrivez pas
à mentir mais c'est un test un peu
grossier quand même c'est assez lourd
bah c'est vous qui êtes lourd là ah bon
bah oui vous j'y arrivez pas ah d'accord
ou là ou là ou là ou là ou là ou là
non la baston quoi quoi je le
démolis ja t picolé c'est bon
voilà
Jack l'interview
mensonge vous avez du mal à mentir quand
même c'est bien c'est bien on a vu là
vous narz pas à mentir votre fan doit
être ravi Anto ser on va expliquer donc
à nos amis téléspectateurs le jeu du
Homar donc si des fois il y avait des
des execo blind test alors le principe
est simple il suffit de tomber en même
temps que le Homar et si des fois il y
avait un petit doute on ferait un petit
replay Serge
attention
att tomber en même
temps attention
attention oh là là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pardon regardons le replay au ralenti
c'est baffi qui aurait
gagné regard regard le replay
[Applaudissements]
ou
ou MAM
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
bravo et
[Musique]
oui j'appelle Boris LEC de fourque il a
envoyé un email en disant qu'il voulait
participer au jeu du Homar Boris
[Applaudissements]
asseez-vous et pour s'opposer à Boris le
bonsoir asseyez-vous j'appelle de
nouveau monsieur
philippeti
connaissez le
principeandom est comme ça vous vous
mettez comme
çail tomber en même temps que le
[Applaudissements]
hom qui a
gagné tolay attention
philippeés et
voil si vous aussi vous
voulezronter je enyail et peutre vous à
vous affronter à Monsieur Philippe voil
voici maintenant un beau mec voici
Samuel
leill
bonsoir c'est vrai que là là cette fois
faut arrêter de raller les filles parce
que vous avez vraiment une belle
brochette là CAD Olivier tu regardes pas
ma meuf comme ça Samuel d'accord non
mais elle peut venir avec nous d'accord
tu as compris tout de suite on a compris
V petit manè tous les
deux tu restes avec l'arménien
toias
il est passé de Corse à arménien en une
émission lui bien il a pas encore parlé
Samuel non non mais Samuel il s'en fout
les cool j'ai remarqué un truc c'est
Bernardo ce
soir tu prépares un rô c'est une bonne
trour c'est
Bernardo bon le Pacte des Loups donc ça
s'appelle cette super production
française c'est un film de Christophe
gant avec Monica Bellucci donc Vincent
casselle Émilie de Ken
qui jouait dans Rosetta jean-yan
Jean-François Stevenin Jacques Perin
Bernard Fresson enfin il y a un casting
d'enfer jy reenier aussi c'est vrai
cette histoire quand vous êtes arrivé
sur le tournage vous avez dit que la
caravane de Vincent casselle était plus
grande que la vôtre c'est vrai que ça me
faisait chier de me sentir inférieur
quoi j'avais pas envie de qu'on me dise
voilà là il y a la star et toi tu es
ouais alors je vais le même âge dans le
même film bon il est un peu plus connu
que vous Vincent cass ou c'est vraiou et
alors non vous faites très soigneusement
votre boulot vous hein vous êtes un vous
êtes un artisan ouais c'est c'est mon
côté ouvrier mais c'est bien oui ben
c'est ça il y a vous dites il y a plein
de manières de faire ce métier il y a le
mec pépère tranquille qui fait un petit
film par an bon il y a le mec qui passe
ses soirées à prendre de la coque ou de
l'héros et dans les soirées vous êtes
l'artisan vous croyez à la force du
travail bah je l' je l'ai découvert un
peu sur le tard au moment où je me suis
mis à faire quelque chose c'est quand
j'ai commencé à faire comédien j'avais
19 ans et là je me suis rendu compte si
si bah il y AA eu du boulot quoi il y a
pas mal de choses à faire et et voilà
c'est vous dites c'est effectivement
très ouvrier comme façon de penser mais
vous êtes d'un milieu d'ailleurs où on
pense comme ça un milieu ben voilà c'est
mes référence bien alors votre père
était était marin pêcheur breton puis un
jour il est venu dans la dans la banl
Parisienne ça la banl parisienne il est
venu laveur de vitre et votre mère
faisait des ménages donc c'est vrai que
c'était une enfance quand même non non
pas mal non non pas difficile non on a
toujours bien mangé bien c'est bien on
en voit un qui se PL pas non c'était
super quoi vous une adolescence un peu
chaotique quand même ouais parce que
j'étais pas j'ai pas tellement fait pour
le milieu scolaire donc for forcment
comme c'est un passage obligé et que on
vous dit tous les jours vous êtes le
dernier c'est un peu humantou c'est
humant quoi et quand on veut exister
quand même et qu'on est dernier à
l'école bah pour épater les autres on va
gagner la gloire dans la rue voilà dans
dans la cour d'école vous dites
d'ailleurs la fierté on va la chercher
dans les S coups dans le risque et quand
on pique quelque chose B ça devient
héroïque quoi c'est-à-dire que vous ce
qui vous rendez héroïque c'était pas les
premiers les bonnes notes vous étiz pas
premiers de la
classe c'était les petites conneries que
vous faisiez quoi ouais les petites
conneries mais j'ai jamais été un
méchant de toute façon ouais vous AZ
vous avez pu mal finir quand même ah
j'aurais pu continuer les conneries mais
j'ai eu des des bonnes rencontres oui
c'est ça il y a un mec un soir vous av
discuté avec lui sortit de prison le mec
ouais mais j'en étais pas là non plus
c'est vrai que le mec vous a dit moi
j'ai raté ma vie fais pas la même
connerie quoi alors le déclic pour vous
c'est incroyable la vie moi ça me
fascine l'histoire des gens c'estàd
qu'un jour vous allez vous accompagner
des copains au cour Florent et vous
dites finalement ça a l'air sympa ce
métier à l'époque vous vouliez faire les
beauards et vous dites c'est sympa et je
vais faire comédien ou ouais il y a ça
ou escroc quoi que quoi que c'est un peu
pareil en même temps mais le problème
c'est que vous avez été obligé d'arrêter
le courfan par manque de fric parce que
voilà et vous partez faire le tour
d'Europe alors ça c'est incroyable quel
courage vous partez faire le tour
d'Europe il le MIM dans les rues alors
bon il manquait la parole mais en même
temps c'est c'était c'était du jeu quoi
et puis voilà il y a une rue il y a rien
et on se dit là va y avoir un théâtre va
y avoir des spectateurs je vais faire un
spectacle et avec ça ben je me
débrouillis je gagnais bien ma vie donc
je voyageais quoi faisz quoi cracher du
feu je j'ai appris un moment j'ai
rencontré le cracheur de feu il m'a
appris à à le faire un petit peu voilà
bon c'était marrant il faut pas je dis
faut pas faut pas aver
l'essence faut la garder là vous jonglez
ouais un petit peu comme ça vous marchez
sur les mains
ouais il sa'est faire ça Olivier Picasso
non pas encore après au retour de cette
de ce voyage quoi donc vous faisiez le
MIM vous faisiez du spectacle de
rue vous présentez le le le
conservatoire et vouliez faire une scène
de bagarre c'est original ouais et vous
amenez vos meubles parce que vous dites
on va pas leur casser leur meuble ils
nous ont pris pour des fous quoi c'est
la première fois jeis les mecs il ont le
meu ils ont au Conservatoire
le ça les a fait rire et puis bon vous
en prie en même temps gr bah ouis bien
sûr mais en même temps bon vous êtes au
Conservatoire vous partez un an à New
York vous vivez à Harlem vous vous
déchargez des camions dans le Bronx non
mais à New York j'en ai j'en ai ch j'is
vraiment chieré mais mais voilà j'ai
appris tellement de choses et puis
cétait un espèce de parcours initiatique
en même temps je voulais apprendre
j'avais la fascination des de l'Amérique
et ben voilà j'ai pris ma claque et
j'étais content quoi et aujourd'hui ça
va très bien ça ouais ça va vous
commencez à gagner des sous là oui j'ai
vu vous annonciz combien vous gagnez
c'est pas mal
payé donc non genre il gagnait toujours
700 800000 balles par film avant et là
pour le Pacte des lou il a pris 18 quand
même ça vaut le coup de se faire chier
dans la boue à saint-ché d'apch fait
cher la boue mér oui sauf que tu files
60 % aux impôts quand même oui bien sûr
il y a l'agent il y a tout le monde qui
croque mais mais bon c'est c'est énorme
quand même c'est énorme ce que je dis ça
représente ce qui en un an je gagne ce
que mon père gagna en toute une vie donc
faut faut mettre les pieds sur terre
mais c'est bien voilà en même temps on
est content pour vous he en même temps
ça je suis libre alors vous vous avez
profité maintenant vous êtes un peu
calmé vous avez bien profité de votre
succès quand même hein vous êtes non
mais c'est vrai les boîtes vous avez pas
le droit de rentrer bah vous y êtes allé
pour voir comment c'était à l'intérieur
les resto où on peut jamais aller parce
qu'on a pas de tune vous allez pour voir
ce qu'on mange et comment voilà et puis
il y a eu aussi les filles quoi ou vous
dites et voir nu des filles j'aime bien
cette phrase et voir nu des filles
inaccessibles c'est vra le jour on pe
les
d la fille que tu vois en photo dans
elle si tu veux le jour elle est nul
devant toi tu dis merde quandme c'est
bien le tu rencre tu la baratine et puis
mais
mais mais vous bon oui je suis parti un
petit peu dans tous les excès parce que
je voulais j'avais une fascination pour
ça du temps à rattraper bien sûr oui oui
on pe dire ça oui alors vous dites
certains couchent pour réussir moi j'ai
réussi pour
coucher salant non non mais c'est vrai
c'est
vrai alors maintenant ça va être
terrible pour vous on ne bouge pas
pendant le
[Applaudissements]
jingle ah
j'ai bougé merde à cause de toi moi
aussi j'ai bougé est-ce que vous
préférez votre père ou votre
mère j'ai averti hein c'est pas possible
je peux pas répondre à ça non je peux
pas je suis je vois Monseigneur Di Falco
qui attend là-bas rassurez-vous mon
Seigneur cette interview on l'a fait à
Samuel lebillan donc vous y avez échappé
de factoè bien alors plus simple est-ce
que vous préférez Staline ou
Hitler V j'ai envie de dire Staline mais
c'est pour par a tué plus de gens voilà
cétait plus et puis c'est c'est un peu
plus plus méconnu c'est un peu moins
proche quoi VO oui d'accord oui les
Français sont moins informés du goulac
que que de sch c'est vrai euh est-ce
alors ça c'est déjà plus simple
euh vous êtes 3 ans dans un vaisseau
spatial est-ce que vous préférez partir
avec cadoo ou Bataille et
Fontaine tu dis ce que tu veux on t'en
voudra pas tu dis ce que tu veux on ira
voir le film quand même je connais un
peu plus j'ai déjà vu le émissions et et
voilà ça me fait mar
c'est gentil bonne Bour les mecs
son per de
maquillage n pas entre nous ah non ah du
tout tous les
deux oh oh
forti fais mal tu
fa il se
cal bien alors vous
partez la ququette elle me passe la
ququette monsieur Ardisson dans votre
émission monsieur Ardisson elle me passe
la ququette
c'est pas trop service public ça quand
même hein alors chaudass vous partez sur
une île déserte si vous partez sur une
île déserte est-ce que vous préférez
partir avec un mec très beau ou une
fille très laide fille très laide vous
êtes pas [__] du tout vous mais pas du
tout non mais désolé clair ah non mais à
ce point là j'ai jamais vu ça quand même
vous préférez ah oui vous préférez une
fille très l qu'un mec très beau ah de
toute façon au bout de de jours je la
trouverai très belle
donc
jours 2
jours Sam
jours en plus est toute petite j'ai
oublié de dire il y a pas on peut pas se
planquer hein est-ce que vous accordez
plus de circonstances éénuante à un
vieux qui se tape des petite ou un jeune
qui tape sur les vieilles c'est quel âge
les
petites 14 ans 14 ans c'est rude ouais
je préfère celui qui t'appé vieilles ah
ouais je vous rappelle des bon souvir en
plus
bon votre punition préférée c'est être
pincé mordu ou piqué
am mordu j'aime bien
ah le mot le plus con en amour c'est
merci encore ou oui
oui ça dépend dans quelle langue a aussi
yes yes oua ça dit merci c'est très con
ça sentend qu'on a rien
foutu
merci alors Samuel si vous aviez un
perroquet imaginez que vous aviez un
perroquet vous lui apprendriez quoi
comme phrase tu as fermé le gaz tu as
pensé à la capote
ou coco arrête la
coco j'avais averti c'est les question
son con ah oui c'est clair c'est clair
ouais la dernière est
bien c'est utile les perroquets ah oui
ça c'est terrible ça vous trouvez votre
fiancée au lit avec de par
dieux ça ça c'est chiant qu'est-ce que
fait qu'est-ce que vous faites oh
iléclate vous
restez qu'est-ce que vous faites alors
vous restez vous mettez au lit avec eux
et je regarde vous vous regardez oui
vous giflez votre fiancé vous boudez
vous tuez ou vous parlez boulot parce
que si ça peut je sodomise de Part
Dieu
Catherine me dit c'est vrai Catherine
c'est prodrice de l'émission elle dit
pour un mec qui est pas [__] il se
domise facilement de Part
Dieu ah ouis bien vu Catherine bien vu
et dès quealco est là on arrête
conneries voilà Samuel leillan donc à
l'affiche du Pacte des Loups de
Christophe G qui sort le 31
janvier voilà alors on compare souvent
cette émission à un dîner en ville et
dans tout bon dîner en ville qui se
respecte il y a un évêque voici
Monseigneur Di
[Applaudissements]
Falco Monseigneur du Falco bonsoir
bonsoir CAD Alice Evens Olivier Patrick
Fiori compatriote ah oui c'est vrai ah
oui ah oui c'est vrai vous êtes
marseillais tous alors vous êtes évêque
auxiliaire de Paris chargé des
communautés catholiques étrangères des
prêtres étrangers des relations avec
l'Islam et le judaïsme vous êtes
responsable de la communication du
diocèse de radio notred-dame et d'une
chaîne de télé catholique qui s'appelle
Cato Kate Cato Cato et champion de
France de karaoké vous le saviez oui je
savais bien enseigné oui quand quand
vous parlez de la télé vous dites la
télé c'est comme une religion il y a une
liturgie il y a une une célébration à
heure fixe et c'est pas par hasard qu'on
appelle le journal télévisé la grand
messe euh d'ailleurs vous avez vu je
suis habillé en pergiman moi hein
Presque Oui je peut-être un petit col
comme vous la prochaine fois vous voulez
ouis non mais j'aimerais bien ah bon oui
vous voulez ça c'est énorme c'est énorme
ça c'est énorme ah c'est génial fais
voirme prenez-le ah ah c'est la première
fois de ma vie là qu'est-ce que
c'est à partir du moment où tu vas
mettre ça Thierry plus de sexe mais
attention si vous le prenez vous le
gardez surtout au mois d'août et vous
verrez comme c'est agréable ah ouais
c'est oui c'est c'est c'est du
celluloïde non oui très chaud ça va me
valoir 150 lettres à peu près oui ça me
va bien ouou mais vous l'avez mis à
l'envers mais ça fait non mais parce que
ça fait un peu col comme ça vous dites
en parlant de de la chaîne de télé donc
cateo qu'est-ce qu'il y a on te respecte
vachement plus bah ouai attendez
déconnez pas on te voit différemment en
plus moi j'aurais très bien pu être curé
en plus je suis pas passé loin j'étais
élevé chez les curés et tout puis je je
vis un petit peu comme un moine oui oui
bien sûr donc alors vous dites que pour
créer une chaîne de télé c'est comme
construire construire une église
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas relever un
défi mais c'est accomplir un devoir que
finalement il est naturel que l'Église
c'est la vocation de l'Église c'est la
communication et il est naturel que
l'Église communique c'est comme quand
elle faisait des des des façades de
cathédrale finalement ça communiquait
bah il y a eu les livres il y a eu la
radio il y a internet la télé donc il
est naturel que l'Église est une chaîne
de télévision oui si on considère que la
place publique des temps modernes c'est
la télévision h autrefois lorsqu'on
voulait s'informer on sortait de chez
soi on allait sur la place du village
pour rencontrer les autres pour écouter
ce qu'il se disait aujourd'hui c'est
l'inverse si on veut s'informer on
rentre chez soi on regarde la télévision
donc si l'Église veut être présente dans
cette polyphonie de tout ce qui se dit
de tout ce qui se su ah ben je ne sais
pas alors pas polyphonie parce que voilà
il faut pas le dire non non parce
qu'après lui d'accord enfin vous
comprendez ce que je veux donc ce lieu
d'échange de dialogue et bien si elle
veut être présente il faut qu'elle soit
aussi présente dans le cadre de la
télévision alors cette chaîne donc Cato
on la trouve sur nous en région
parisienne et sur Canal Sat au niveau
européen voilà alors il y a quand même 5
millions de de gens qui pourraient la
regarder en toutous les cas si vous la
regardez ça marche bien oui avec des
moyens très modestes mais oui oui ça
marche bien alors on va parler d'actu
puis après on parlera de choses un petit
peu plus fondamentales rendez mon col
ouais ouais parce que là je sens que
c'est c'est vous avez ça toute la
journée autour du coup quoi oui terrible
hein bon s'habitue hein c'est comme une
cravate non mais je sais mais femme
quand elle son collier de chien elle se
plain aussi allez merci merci alors
Monseigneur Di Falco vous vous êtes vous
êtes un immigré finalement vous êtes la
trisème génération
d'immigré italoc Corse un mélange de
d'Italie et de Corse voilà qui sont
arrivés à Marseille donc finalement vous
êtes un travailleur immigré enfin votre
famille en toutous les cas c'est des
travailleurs
immigrés c'est une famille qui était
catholique mais pas praticante et vous
alliez à la messe en cachette quand vous
étiez petit je servais la messe en
cachette ouais jusqu'à ce que la
première me dénonce alors bah vous avez
pas eu une enfance très drôle vous non
plus mais enfin vos parents se séparent
vous êtes très jeunes vous grandissez
dans 20 m² à Marseille avec votre mère
et votre sœur votre père vous l'avez
revu 42 ans plus tard donc c'est pas
hein c'est pas dû être une enfance très
drôle et un jour vous avez un flash quoi
c'està-dire qu'il a une une voisine qui
vous emmène à la messe à la paroisse
injuste et là qu'est-ce qui se passe
bien là c'est une image fait que j'ai
gardé je dois avoir 3 ou 4 ans sans
doute je suis entré pour la première
fois dans une église et le souvenir que
j'ai c'est à la fois l'ambiance assez
sombre de l'église et puis au bout de ce
tunnel quelque chose de très lumineux
c'était le l'ôtel le cœur le cœur qui
étaitum qui illuminé et à partir de ce
jour-là sans trop savoir ce que ça
voulait dire quand on me demandait ce
que je voudrais faire plus tard je
disais je voudrais que je voulais être
prêtre sans vraiment savoir sais pas ce
que ça signifiait mais c'est c'est ce
que j'ai dit à partir de ce moment-là et
alors après bon bah vous grandissez ce
désir est un petit peu en en sommeil et
un jour dans votre paroisse il y a le
curé et le vicaire qui tombe malade en
même temps le curé est mort d'ailleurs
et et et là les jeunes de la paroisse
prennent un petit peu à cœur de de les
remplacer et là vous sentez ce ce désir
de d'être prêre revenir et vous prenez
le relais vous faites toutes les toutes
les tâches qui incombaient
habituellement au prêtres et et au et au
vicaire et là l'appel est impérieux et
vous dites il faut que je sois
disponible pour le Christ et bien à ce
moment-là je pense que si je veux être
heureux il faut que je réponde à cet
appel ouais je peux dire que c'est un
choix difficile parce que j'avais 18 ans
j'étais très amoureux et j'ai dû faire
un choix ouais
et on sait maintenant le choix que j'ai
fait mais c'est vraiment je me suis
trouvé confronté à à à ce choix-là oui
c'est à 18 ans vous vous étiez avec une
fille vous dites c'est elle fait des
études médicales he la fille et vous
dites c'est l'époque a changé on nosait
pas se prendre la main c'est à peine
c'est ce qu'on osait à peine faire ou
ouais et quand vous lui avez annoncé à
cette fille votre intention de devenir
prêtre comment elle a réagi elle est
devenue
majorette dans ce cas-là quand on aime
quelqu'un ben c'est un peu de de de
souffrance et de tristesse mais après
très bien et lorsqu'elle s'est mariée
avec un de mes amis je suis devenu le
Parin de son dans son premier enfant
vous elle av un an de plus que vous hein
oui il sait tout hein c'est
extraordinaire et il sait tout incroable
vous avez déclaré dans le Figaro Madame
en 92
euh
dans la vie de prêtre renoncer à la
sexualité n'est pas une chose acquise
une fois pour toutes il peut lui arriver
comme à un homme marié d'être infidèle à
ses promesses euh c'est une épreuve
douloureuse mais c'est pas pour autant
qu'il restera enfermé dans le péché
toute sa vie c'est un peu sibin quand
même est-ce que ça veut dire que vous
admettezir dit ça mais je cité la source
donc c'est pour ça j'ai noté la source
mon é à à discussion mais enfin dire
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il restera
enfermé dans le péché toute sa vie ça
veut dire que vous c'est pas cibilein
non mais ça veut dire que vous admettez
donc qu'un prêtre peut craquer un moment
bien sûr c'est pas le fait que j'admette
ou pas dans dans dans dans une vie
d'homme qui que l'on soit prête ou que
l'on soit marié il peut arriver en effet
que que l'on soit infidèle à sa femme
comme infidèle au choix qu'on a fait
c'est pas pour autant qu'on reste dans
cette situation de façon définitive et
on peut donc sortir de cette situation
alors en même temps il faut pas gêner
dire c'est le cas pour tous les prêtres
mais ça peut arriver dans une vie de
prêtres alors est-ce que en parlant du
célibat des prêtres c'est là où je
comprends pas vous dites il a jamais été
autant nécessaire qu'aujourd'hui parce
qu'il a une telle confusion entre
l'amour et le désir qu'il est important
qui d'un côté le désir de l'autre côté
l'amour c'est pas complètement la même
chose et le sébat des prêtres est très
important oui je voulais dire sans doute
que à une époque justement où on a on a
tendance à à faire cette confusion entre
l'amour avec un A majuscule et puis le
fait que on se rencontre soir un dîner
on se trouve sympa on couche ensemble et
puis on se revoit plus c'est pas de
l'amour ça d'ord désir c'est du désir
ouis donc que des hommes et des femmes
fassent un autre
choix pour montrer qu'il est possible
d'aimer autrement et que l'amour peut
aussi se déployer s'exprimer autrement
que dans la sexualité ou dans le mariage
bien je pense que c'est un un témoignage
dès l'instant où il est choisi
volontairement que l'on peut donner oui
mais de l'amour oui bien sûr mais enfin
moi je sais pas quand je vois par
exemple des des prêtres des les curés
comme ça qui sont arrêtés ça arrive il y
en a il y en a quand même beaucoup
chaque année qui sont arrêtés pour des
agressions sexuelles sur sur sur des sur
des enfants moi j'ai honte d'être
catholique quand je vois ça je vous dis
franchement j'ai honte et moi je suis
contre le célibat des prêtres à cause de
ça parce que je me dis que si ces mecs-l
ils avaient une vie normale s'ils avait
une femme comme le Rabin à une femme
comme le pasteur à une femme il serait
pas obligé de se jeter sur des gamins ou
des gamines de 15 ans j'entends bien ce
que vous dites mais vous oubliez
peut-être aussi que parmi ceux qui se
trouvent dans ces situation il y a
également des pères de famille et des
hommes mariés ouais h
ouais bonne réponse de
monseigneurco c'est répété c'est répondu
Samuel vous en pensez quoi vous moi j'ai
j'ai eu une période où j'étais vers
l'âge de 15 16 ansù j'étais très un peu
désespéré je suis allé voir un curé
ouais et j'ai parlé avec lui non mais
c'est sérieux et il m'a donné beaucoup
de force et beaucoup d'aide et j'ai lu
les
évangiles il m'a donné sans j'ai été
baptisé mais j'ai pas euh fait ma
communion donc il m'a donné la
permission de de prendre l'osti de
communier
et ça a duré un an et puis après bon
j'ai je sais pas j'en voulais à Dieu
quoi j'avais du mal à admettre euh en
fait un petit peu j'avais du mal à
comprendre la relation entre Dieu qui
vous donne de la force et et toute la
souffrance qu'il y a sur la terre c'est
un peu généraliste mais mais avec mes
yeux de 15 ans j'avais du mal à à faire
la jonction
et mais ça m'arrive encore de prier
parce que ça me donne beaucoup de force
ça me permet de me repérer mais voilà
bon le le seul voilà le seul acte
véritable c'est d'avoir lu les évangiles
quoi mais c'est je dirais que c'est
l'acte principal c'est l'acte
fondamental ce qui est fascinant dans
les évangiles c'est que on peut le
prendre à n'importe quelle page quoi
quoi qui nous arrive on peut le prendre
à n'importe quelle page et déf quiconque
dans les deux pages de lecture de pas
trouver la solution à son problème quoi
de pas trouver la force
à voilà montagne je m' remets à lui
ouais quelque fois et puis oui moi je
peux je je l'ai dit dans dans dans dans
certains journaux mais oui je je je fais
ma prière quoi c'est clair ben avant de
rentrer je me suis signé tout simplement
ici avant de venirouais parce que je
c'est bien quand vous venez ici vous
avez intérêt à faire le signe de la
croix avant parce que pour envenir à
notre discussion c'est vrai que le
message du Christ est le message le plus
révolutionnaire de tous les temps parce
que si on vivait il faut bien se
souvenir quand même on vivait dans une
époque d'esclavage à l'époque il y avait
des esclaves dans la Grèce antique dans
la Rome antique il y avait des esclaves
bon et puis un jour il arrive et il dit
on est tous frères aimez-vous les uns
les autres c'est le message le plus
révolutionnaire de tous les temps c'est
évident mais c'est vrai que ce message
est souvent brouillé pour le pour le
public moi je le vois autour de moi par
finalement des positions réactionnaires
de l'église alors prenons les exemples
concrets le préservatif par exemple le
pape est contre le préservatif le pape
n'a jamais parlé du préservatif jamais
dans aucun texte la position de l'Église
sur cette question du préservatif et la
suivante si vous voulez vivre l'idéal de
votre foi je dis bien l'idéal de votre
foi et bien si vous êtes marié vous êtes
fidèle et avant votre mariage vous
n'avez pas de relation sexuelle si vous
voulez vivre l'idéal mais si vous ne
parvenez pas à vivre cet idéal là c'est
évident que vous non seulement vous
pouvez mais que vous devez utiliser le
préserv
vous ni suicidaire ni suicidaire ni
criminel ce que vous d c'est quand on
est pas capable de de de de faire
l'abstinence disons c'estàdire de pas
baiser
est
incable on a le droit de
mettreés attendez vous éteignez chez
vous et on éteint ici
aussi donc ce que vous dites mon
Seigneur di Falco ce soir c'est que un
catholique peut très bien utiliser un
préservatif et tout le monde pu des
préservatif c'est pas condamné par le
Vatican à partir du moment où vous ne
parvenez pas à vivre l'idéal de fidélité
par exemple et que vous avez des
relations sexuelles et bien vous ne P on
peut pas prendre de risque d'être soit
criminel soit suicidaire il faut
utiliser le préservatif je crois que
c'est une question de bon sens attende
ça non mais attendez ça c'est la
position de Monseigneur Di Falco qui est
à Paris ou la position du pape la
position c'est la position expliquelé de
façon claire de
l'église bien on
rallume ça ouvre des horizons quand même
he
alors maintenant alors toujours sur ces
problèmes là finalement ce sont des
problèmes bon l'avortement vous dites
vous sur l'avortement vous dites quand
on est contre la peine de mort on doit
être contre l'avortement bon donc
l'église est quand même contre
l'avortement il y a pas de discussion
là-dessus pas bon la pilule pareil
l'église est contre la pilule tout moyen
de contraception artificielle ah oui
préservatif alors le préservatif pas le
préservatifz
la le préservatif s'il est utilisé dans
le sens que vous dites il est un moyen
de contraception mais il se trouve qu'il
est aussi un moyen de protection contre
une malad et VO c'est ça est génial on a
trouvé la ouais d'accord donc
l'avortement non la pilule non le
stérilet non enfin voilà et cetera on
pas faire toute la liste non non va pas
faire toute la liste parce qu'il y en a
des trucs il y a des moyens préservatifs
qu'on peut pas a des moyens pour pas
avoir d'enfants qu'on peut pas raconter
à la télé doncon boî de sardine
rouillée
l'euthanasie non non vous êtes quand on
est contre la peine de mort on est
contre l'euthanasie c'est j'imagine je
crois que tout se résume dans le fait
que la vie la vie d' de de nôre on n pas
le droit de décider de la vie ou de la
mort de notre être humain même lorsqu'il
est atteint par une maladie grave je
crois mais je comprends très bien t tous
les arguments je me place moi sur le
plan humain si je me trouvais dans cette
situation je comprends les arguments je
crois que pour comprendre la la position
de l'Église par rapport à ça il faut se
dire qu'à partir du moment où on
commencerait à introduire des exceptions
jusqu'où ça va ouais en fait c'est ça
c'est à partir du moment dit mais dans
telles condition peut-être qu'il on
pourrait en vis qui qui va qui va qui va
le gérer ça tu as 16 ans tu as pas
d'argent tu as une fille voilà et aussi
tuas une famille qui a déjà h enfants ou
il veent faire l'amour ils peuvent pas
faire l'amour parce qu'ils ont pas de
préservatif ils peuvent pas utiliser les
préservatif moy de cont bien tout ça
mais mais c'est que les évangiles enfin
la religion c'est pas fait pour être
pour épouser l'URE du temps hein c'est
une morale c'est une loi est-ce qu'on a
le droit de jouer est-ce qu'on ait de
jou la Playstation oui la deux seulement
la deux revent TER là mais habé
bon ça dépend quel jeu elle m' embrasser
tu peux recommencer parce personne NAB
elle m'embrasserembrasser aussi ouis bon
alors l'euthanasie on a vu alors le le
les couples homosexuels est-ce que
l'Église admet qu'un homme vive avec un
homme se paxe ou une femme avec une
femme non mais je sais pas on non mais
c'est normal mon Seigneur attendez on se
pose des questions c'est logique mais
oui pour l'Église je pense pas seulement
pour l'Église une famille c'est un homme
et une femme néanmoins pour régler un
certain nombre de problèmes de de de
couple homosexuel elle n'était pas
opposée au fait que que la législation
soit revue et qu' et que soit réglé par
ce biais-là un certain nombre de
questions ce qu'elle n'admet pas c'est
qu'on mette sur le même plan la famille
constitué d'un homme et d'une femme et
puis un couple homosexuel qui s'agisse
de deux hommes ou de deux femmes
d'accord alors vous avez vu il y a un
livre qui est sorti là qui est un livre
important qui est un livre de René
Raymond on en a parlé d'ailleurs la
semaine dernière ici euh c'est un livre
où René Raymond dit que finalement
aujourd'hui la la religion catholique en
France est victime enfin toute
proportion gardez évidemment de la même
intolérance dont était victime le le
judaïsme à l'époque
euh maltraité sarcasme et cetera et
c'est vrai quand on voit au guignol le
le pape qui prend de la coque par
exemple on na jamais vu le grand Rabin
prendre de la coque ou le recteur de la
Mosquée de Paris prendre de la coque
alors est-ce que ça vous par rapport à
ça vous réagissez comment c'est vrai
qu'il y a un certain ralbol par rapport
à ça h c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment que le catholicisme le
christianisme et le catholicisme en
particulier une sorte de Bou émissèire
il se trouve que nous quand on nous
roule dans la farine ou dans la boue on
ne menace personne de mort h voilà
peut-être que d'autres ont d'autres
moyens qui faut car Lagerfeld avait fait
une ceinture vous l' pas fait exprès il
y avait un verset du Coran sur la
ceinture les islamistes sont menacés de
désing dans tradition de menacer les
gens de mort alors c'est peut-être pour
ça que bien on se permet un certain ch
c'est pour ça que c'est plus facile pour
les guignoles sans doute
m temp
c'estour lour arê
Angleterre plus facilement l'église
Samuel oui je disais en même temps bon
c'est de l'humour quoi c'est c'est de la
blague faut qu'on puisse aussi se moquer
de l'église qu m toujours les mêmes qui
prennent ça bien sûr que oui
parfaitement qu' on se moque de l'église
et qu'on nous caricature pourquoi pas
mais je crois qu'il y a des moments où R
bien alors maintenant on va passer c'est
Monseigneur Di Falco à l'ardy viw on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle on ne bouge
pas pendant le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jingle très bien vous avez l'habitude de
pas bouger he parce qu' la messe aussi
il y a des moments on bouge pas moments
on doit baisser la tête et tout donc
c'est un peu pareil finalement c'est une
espèce de grande messe ici le samedi
soir vous pensez à quoi là mais vous
disiez c'est une espèce de je disais oui
de liturgie vous vous dites quoi le
matin quand vous vous vous voyez dans le
miroir j'évite de me regarder à ce
moment-là ce qui vous énerve le plus en
vous la chose que vous supportez le
moins chez vous euh ma gueule pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle a ta gueule parce que
non parce que parce que c'est tellement
l' ça a tellement été l'objet de de
colibé de toutes sortes que je
préférerais avoir quelqu visage plus
anonyme ah non mais vous avez vous avez
une tête pour faire de la télé attendez
arrêtez là ben écoutez je ouais ouais
une tête d'acteur on dirait les oiseaux
se cachent pour mourir et voilà
allons-ylin allons-y non mais c'est vrai
mais c'est bien attendez champ-berlin
est formidable est-ce que vous seriez
prêt à tout quitter pour le grand amour
alors imaginez non mais sérieusement
vous rencontrez une fille comme ça non
mais est-ce que vous seriez prêt à
abandonner votre état euh de prêtre euh
est-ce que vous l'imaginez ça oou est-ce
que vous pensez que maintenant très
c'est très difficile de se projeter dans
cette situation là à froid à froid là je
vais vous dire non mais je n mais bien
sûr que ça peut arriver
je ne sais pas vous pourriez tout
quitter pour le grand amour mais je ne
sais pas ouais ben vous dites pas non
hein qu'est-ce que vous faites la
dernière chose que vous faites avant de
vous coucher le soir je vais regarder
mes messages sur Internet ah oui vous
êtes un curé moderne oui si c'était à
refaire votre vie vous referiez la même
chose
oui oui je ferai le même choix que celui
que j'ai fait vous diriez la même chose
à la fille à l'époque de 17 ans vous
regrettez pas ça non quel est le péché
qui vous tente le plus mais ça je le
réserve à mon
confesseur vous pensez pas que je suis
un confesseur même si je vous prête
çaord malgré tous mes eff je n'arrive
pas à confesser
monseigneurco merci beaucoup en tous les
cas merci de
vanchise merci beaucoup au revoir
Monseigneur
mer merci
beaucoup tu pouris moner quand même peux
partout
parfois je dis des choses je dis des
choses que je ne pense pas ou j'ai pas
envie de dire parce que il faut
justifier un quotat de connerie pouroi
tu fais
ça reste ton fauteuil tu fais
chier se chamaille on doit vous appeler
comment h d'orlé mon Seigneur toujours
mon Seigneur pu si c'était mon seigneur
ou ma
couille alors j'accueille
maintenant m'appelle non j'accueille
maintenant voici maintenant h
[Musique]
P vous comprenez pourquoi on fait ce
métier quand même
l'air Catherine me dit dans elle a l'air
de plaire à Jonas oui
ctherine
bon alors vous avez fait des films mLINE
de Fougerol avec Jean-Pierre my avec
Rivette avec clapich avec dev ville avec
cassovit avec Jof vous êtes on va en
parler dans le nouveau film de
Jean-Jacques benex qui s'appelle mortel
transfert et pourtant personne ne vous
connaî et ouais et
pourquoi c'est pas ça mais presque c'est
vrai que vous avez une carrière qui
quand même ant à 11 ans d'existence
c'est pas rien 9 ans 9 ans seulement
ouais vous êtes prometteuse on dit he
mais vous êtes pas encore vous AZ pas
encore trouvé le rôle qui va vous qui va
vous révéler au grand public et pourtant
quand on voit jouer et on va parler de
du films de benex vous êtes vous êtes
excellente qu'elle est
bonne alors il y a eu que la lumière
soie dont vous attendiez beaucoup le
film de jofé c'est que ça pas été un
énorme succès mais c'est làdedans que
benex vous a vu non ouais il y a eu le
prof de jardin voilà voilà ça pas été
non plus un succès énorme la plage vous
étiez la plage avec Virginie le doyen et
Leonardo DiCaprio vous ont coupé au
montage non j'avais une grande scaîne
qui durait 2 secondes et qui a découpé
au montage ou mais mais j'y suis allée
je savais que ça allait pas être mais
tout le monde a confiance en votre
carrière tout le monde cro y arver non
mais c'est vrai doute non non vous vous
doutez pas j'espère regardez Jonas il
nous expliquit tout à l'heure que lui
alors c'est vrai vous avez jamais une
certitude absolu il savait qu' allit y
arrivver en même temps c'est
Jonas alors votre vrai nom c'est Hélène
riguan de Fougerol de Fougerol de
Fougerol moi je dirais plutôt Fougerol
mais bon de Fougerol et bon aristo mais
fauché comme tout bon aristo qui se
respecte he VO hein alors vous avez
pensé un moment changé de nom parce qu'
hélè de Fougerol quand même vous aviez
peur que ça fasse un peu mon cul sur la
commode non ouais et aussi on me l'a
proposé ou quelqu'un m'a dit non sur
dans mon film tu peux pas t'appeler
comme ça ça fait un peu ça fait un peu
ouais grande bourgeoise mais mais on a n
de Monique glireuse qui n' marché non
donc j'ai repris Fougerol sans le rigan
mais non mais en même temps c'est c'est
mon c'est mon nom quelque part enfin je
dire ouais Fougerol enfin oui souviv un
peu
con franchement non moi je trouve pas
Fougerol au tableau moi je bouge pas
justement à l'école alors à l'école en
plus vous étiez pas une hein vous étiez
pas super à l'école quand même he non ah
ouais bon désolé vous êtes deux voyez
comme qui c'est un mauvais exemple pour
les jeunes générations parce queils
étaient tous les deux nuls à l'école et
finalement ils réussissent tous les de
vous étiez maigre ouais maig comment là
j'étais maigre j'étais ça c'est le genou
quoi j'étais super
maigre mec racho quoi ouais racho et
puis alors à 16 ans pareil alors vous
chez un jour vous AZ eu marre à 15 ans
en 62 je j'arrête tout euh non 3è 3è 3è
oua ouais elle arrête tout cours de
théâtre et le rêve d'hélè c'était d'être
danseuse au Lido quand j'étais petite
ouais ouais ouais ouais j'avis pas assez
de sa non
ben non c'est écoutez soyez gentil non
parce que moi j'ai du mal à faire c
é en fait j'adorais les les plumes les
paillettes le maquillage les machins et
puis sur scène à faire en fait j'avais
vu ça à la télévision soir du réveillant
c'est l'époque avit des programmes le
soir du réveillant à la télévision exant
comme les annonceurs ils achètent plus
d'espace entre noël et jour il y a plus
de programme incroyable tu voudrais
dénoncer ça à la télé je fais là c'est
le monde moderne bien alors donc vous
réal dis qu'il faut avoir les seins nus
quand on va être dans ceido et là déjà
qu' faut avoir des
seins d'abord ensuite il faut les
montrer et Hélène est extrêmement
pudique viendra
toutour on y viendra tout à l'heure
c'est une soirée je préviens nous montre
ses seins tu montres les tiens si je
montre les tiens faudra qu'il montre
autre
chose bien alors vous vous décidez de
tout plaquer vous plaquez tout et vous
allez faire prendre des des cours ben
j'ai tout plaqué tout le monde je veux
dire l'école m'avait plaqué avant que
j'pr donc et vous partez donc à New York
au l Strasberg Institute pour apprendre
le théâtre mais vous détestez de toute
façon les cours de théâtre vous ont pas
plus amusé pour dire la vérité que que
l'école je trouvais souvent que c'était
des acteurs ratés je voyais pas trop ce
qu'il pouvait m'apporter quo c'est très
méchant ce que je dis mais ils ont pas
été très sympa avec moi non plus donc
voilà il TR non non mais il vous traitez
un peu de godich non non il me disait
mignon tu peux peut-être faire un truc
mais fais autre chose quoi là
franchement un métier pour toi mais
j'étais tellement timide que j'étais
toute j'étais gourdiche ouais ouais
j'étais super timide j'avais tellement
envie que ce soit formidable que voilà
et puis en fait si j'avais besoin d'une
personne qui me dise mais c'est pas mal
tu peux y arriver tu peux le faire et en
fait on m'a donné un peu confiance et
puis voilà là ça va là c'est bien parti
en tous les cas alors il y a eu les
années galères les années galères d'héè
de foueroll donc les spots de pub
notamment le film épouvantable j'ai mais
je le dis de toute façon c'est écrit sur
ma fille je peux pas ne pas le dire le
petit griller tu te souviens pas de ça
ah c'est pas le pire ah bon mais vous es
tout temps en fait vous étiz obligé
d'aller faire du cinéma parce que quand
vous AZ de la pub c'est le petit Grillet
quand vous avez fait mannequin au début
vous commencez dans MarieClaire ça se
termine 3 mois plus tard c'était Canigou
ou frisky ouais biscoc c'était c'était
quoi biscoc
biscocentation pour chien c'est pire que
Canigou là ouais et alors les plans
foireux alors il y a un plan foireux ça
c'est physique hein pas assez de nichon
pour faire la belle deschant c'est c'est
clair c'est pas belle des gens en même
temps euh les plans foireux il y a un
plan que je suis obligé de raconter
parce que je l'adore c'est que donc un
jour à l'époque de la galère cherchait
du boulot tout ça il y a un type qui
l'appelle qui dit voilà je suis photo je
suis cinéaste photographe mais cinéaste
aussi je vais faire un film en septembre
céit en septembre il lui dit mais déjà
faudrait quand même peut-être qu'on se
voit au mois de juin ce serait bien
qu'on VO un petit bout d'essai on va
faire des photos dans le sud au mois non
non j'avais je peux la raconter j'avais
fait des des essais on était super
nombreuse un énorme casting en anglais
dans le monde entier énorme film et
j'avais été prise donc j'avais décroché
le rôle ah ou ouis c'était un gros truc
et il m'a dit on va essayer de venir au
mois de juin parce qu'on va commencer à
faire des photos qui serviront pour le
film
allez-y je vous laisse continuer
nonue vous prenez le train non non moi
j'aime encore mieux que vous le racontez
c'est vous prenez le train train il
vient vous chercher la gare avec la
minioke voilà et il vous amène où et
alors je raconte ça donc j'arrive il
vient me chercher avec sa mini je
m'attendais avir des assistants
maquilleuses coiffeuse dans une superbe
villa du sud de la France je savais pas
du tout où j'étais donc c'est lui qui
vient et et on passe une espèce de
barrag enfin des grandes barrières il
avais des des énormes bâtiments tout
ronds et tout d'un coup je vois un petit
garçon à poil sur un vélo et là je me
dis bon alors je vais être un peu
fatigué et tout et je vois un mec dans
une cabine téléphonique à poil et là
j'étais au Cap d'AG le centre de ah
c'est là le C nudice c'est le bzodrome
le plus grand bodrome d'Europe quoi
c'est je suis super pique quoi je peux
pas M même en Bretagne je pas montrer un
sein et donc je me retrouve là pendant
TR ou 4 jours ça a duré et lui il était
avec une fille ouais et la fille c'est
une bombe atomique hein c'était une
déesse mais elle avait 22 ans et le mec
il pensait qu' était un peu vieille pour
faire des photos de nu donc il voulait
faire des photos avec vous même pour lui
elle était un peu trop passé oua c'est
ça et alors
euh un jour vous partez quand vous
appelez vos parents en Bretagne oui
enfit j'ai essayé de tenir pendant 3
jours alors il fallait vous étiez
attendez vous étiez nuud dans ce camp de
nudis mais c'était horrible desjà on
étaient dans un tout
horble demand si tu é est-ce que pendant
les 4 jours que vous avez passé là-bas
dans un camp de nudiste en général on
est nu non déjà la
part nous fais pas un plan du camp
est-ce que tu soit pas obligé de faire
la question qui tue non plus oui il
avait l'habitude de faire la la plage en
long et en large avec sa bombe atomique
à poil et lui à poil aussi et tout le
monde savait qui il était toi tu suiv en
string et non moi j'étais avec ma
serviette et genre à 2 m de la mer je
regardais je posais ma serviette
j'allais dans l'eau et je les suivais en
agent je se retour en agent pas du tout
et alors ce qui est extra le plus
extraordinaire derrière mais le plus
extraordinaire de l'histoire c'est qu'un
jour vous appelez vos parents qui vous
sortent de là et la fille la bombe
atomique enfin votre mère oui et la
bombe atomique la fille elle part avec
vous en Bretagne vousz marre aussi ça
fait comm j'adore cette histoire voilà
et puis après bon il y a eu il y a eu il
y a eu les premiers films et on a parlé
tout à l'heure les réalisateurs avec qui
vous avez travaillé et maintenant on va
parler bah du dernier film vous savez
comment on fait oui
bravo bien alors le nouveau benex donc
mortel transfert avec jeanhuganglad
ivragier qui est remarquable et y a vous
vous êtes Olga kleptomane
azo elle aime se faire battre par son
mari qui est donc ivrainiier qui la qui
la bat espèce de promoteur ça alors au
début quand il vous parle du personnage
d'lga donc la la MAO parce que le fait
qu'elle soit Klepto c'est pas très grave
mais le fait qu'elle soit Mazo c'est
quand même embêtant au début quand il
vous parle du personnage vous
ça vous choque vous vous préférez dire
non vous vous pensez que jouez l'autre
personnage c'estàdire H qui une
peintesse plutôt sympa non en fait oui
il m'a il m'a décrit Olga en me disant
voilà c'est l'histoire donc d'un PSI qui
rencontre une femme qui est donc
maochiste qui aime se faire frapper
quand elle fait l'amour qui est il me
sort un tableau je fais oui d'accord et
et moi làdedans il me fait ben je pensé
à toi pour le rôle tout je voyais ça
quand même assez je savais pas les
scènes qu'il allait mettre là-dedans
mais j'imaginais tout quoi et et du coup
il m'a écrit le rôle d'héline ouais ah
oui d'accord c'était pour moi voilà donc
mais et un jour il vous a dit ouais mais
pour Olga il faudrait une sacrée
comédienne et ça vous a piqué au vif et
vous avez dit mais je vais le faire
alors non voilà ça ça m'a piqué et
surtout je me suis dit bon ben si je je
me mets pas en danger aujourd'hui si je
fais pas des choses qui me compè
aujourd'hui je pas quand est-ce que je
les ferai et puis voilà alors vous vous
êtes plutôt du genre à être en jean et
en basket nemporter les talons ça lu
être une expérience extraordinaire là je
suis déguisé un peu ah oui faites voir
faites voir vous avez des talons haut là
ah ils sont jolis ah oui oui Ahou uis ce
soir parce que après les sces où h était
en talon
en après sea habiller vite en jean il
vous il vous demande pas votre Jul de
temps en temps de mettre des talons des
portesort il vous supporte en jean toute
la tout le temps mais qui vous dit que
j'ai un Jul
déjà ah ah là je sens beaucoup d'email
beaucoup beaucoup d'email beaucoup
d'email pour avoir le non dites pas ça
si vous dites ça ça y est ça y est ça y
est ça y est moi je vais plus être
pareil après pendant toute l'émission
c'est terrible tu pasis vous demandez à
votre femme de mettre des porches
d'Artel ou ça ah ça peut arriver oui
vrai ah oui vous demandez jamais à votre
compagne de mettre des por je trouve ça
mieux si elle le fait d'elle-même en
fait oui alors vous aviez parce que vous
avez une une petite culotte porte
bonheur vous l'aviez le jour vous a
choisi ah il y a longtemps vous l'avez
plus c ou ben non j'ai non elle do elle
doit être trouvée mainant la culotte par
bonheur c'était il y a au moins 10 ans
bon alors euh vous dites c'est vrai que
votre éducation pris un coup quand vous
avez tourné ce film parce qu'un fille
qui jouit sous les coups par rapport à
ce que vous êtes dans la
vieucation pas une éducation à la con
aristo Cato ni rien c'est mon ma façon
en fait ce qui ce qui me dérangeais
vraiment le plus j'ai aucun mal à à dire
des enfin voilà à dire des horreurs et
et à faire des horreurs j'imaginais
vraiment une scène complètement à poil
qui était dans le scénario le mec était
derrière moi ouais attends va
l'écrire il mettait des grands voilà et
je me disais comment je vais assumer le
truc à poil à quatre pattes en train de
me prendre des cous dans la gueule vous
dites c'est un moment étrange parce que
c'est très violent et j'y ai pris du
plaisir en même temps ou ah ah voilà et
voilà nous y sommes voilà là nous sommes
au cœur de l'émission mesdames Messieurs
le climax du
show ça vous a plu ouais vanchement
c'est tellement pervers c'est tellement
Glo
que j'aurais jamais assumé un truc comme
ça dans la vie enfin je pense pas que ça
me plairait donc prendre des coups et de
ouais prendre du plaisir à ça mais mais
là de jouer ça je trouve ça tellement
pervers j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
choses comme ça un peu dérangeant vous
AZ trouvé du plaisir non j'adorerais
tuer j'adorerais faire des trucs
ignobles c'est ça qui est intéressant
quand on joue en fait hein ça c'est une
façon aussi de d'apprendre à mieux se
connaître quoi de devenir quelqu'un
d'autre et on on se rend compte qu'il
était déjà là qu'il était un peu en soi
tout à fait alors vous aimez pas
tellement vous montrer nu au cinéma
d'une façon générale hein non j'ai j'ai
du mal vous avez déclaré excusez-moi
j'espère que la citation est vraie j'ai
montré mon minou une fois je va plus
recommencer ouais c'est dans quel film
c'est dans quel film qu'onille le voir
tout je diraai pas et tout d'un coup il
va prendre non je veux pas le dire c'est
en plus c'est horrible je me trouve
immonde tout Elizabeth 15 si tu nous
regardes appelle-moi après l'émission
euh benex a essayé de vous mettre tout
nu quand même dans le film ouais ouais
et vous avez pas voulu non ch mais en
plus je lui donné des bons arguments
parce qu'il s'est aperçu que j'avais
raison je dit c'est beaucoup plus
provocateur et et voilà de dire des
horreurs de de que de me mettre à mais
c'est vrai mais la scène est bien de
toute façon la scène il y a une scène où
lui avait raison on voit un
sein j'ai vu un reportage photographique
sur vous dans un journal pour homme qui
s'appelle FHM alors vous dites avec ces
portes jortel j'avais l'impression
d'être un cheval arnaché
euh et pour rester dans la même imagerie
animale dit j'appréhendis ces photos
parce que j'avais peur d'avoir un côté
un peu chienne et finalement je me
trouve sexy donc là aussi finalement ça
a commencé avec le film de benex ça ça
va se terminer avec Marc dorsell faites
gaffe quand même je sais que vous êtes
bien parti là quand même vous commencez
prendre goû non sérieux pardon tu imagin
la cassette la chienne de Fougerol
ça claque vous commencez à y prendre
vous là ouais
ouais quand c'est bien fait quand c'est
bien fait bienit parce que ouais même
même la choupinot là comme vous dites
c'était tellement mal fait comment
j'aurais pu trouver ça même joli à la
fin voilà bien alors on va voir un truc
simplement c'est est-ce que en dehors de
de ce que vous faites dans ce film donc
est-ce que est-ce que vous avez d'autres
penchants un petit peu
pervers bien on bout bouge pas pendant
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jingle bon je si vous êtes Mazo on a
assez parlé vous dites il y a quand même
un certain plaisir à un moment à
imaginer que je pourrais l'être en gros
euh ouais non puis oui non il y a des
situations où de quelque fois je me
demande si je le suis pas un petit peu
ah je vois que vous répondez franchement
c'est bien est-ce que vous êtes sado euh
ouais quand vraiment on m'embête
j'imagine le truc ouais ouis oui c'est
ça mais vous faites pas mal à votre
fiancée comme ça pour lui faire du bien
qui vous pas de chié quelle chance
c'estis qu'à un moment tout le monde a
cru que vous étiez avec Alexandre Jardin
mais je sais on m'a couplé avec Jard je
dire on était on était
effondréc après on a cru que j'étiis
avec benex ouais Rivette
personnement'emmerdé Rivette il y a pas
de problème non plus non plus moi non
plus mittho oui un peu mittho ouais oui
oui ça fait du bien fa il faut un peu
dans les métiers qu'on fait oui parano
parano oui beaucoup ouais et je retiens
toutes les ben comme tout le monde je
crois tous les trucs mauvais on retient
et puis tous les compliments mauvaises
critiques et tout euh oui ou tout d'un
coup on va me dire un truc à la C je
vais pas donner de perch mais
bon quoi par exemple tout va bien non
mais il est sage ce soir je
trouve est-ce que vous êtes exibo bah
pas trop là puisque capdaac vous aviez
la serviette et vous nagiez bon c'est
pas trop gérono les vieux les vieux de
51 ans est-ce que je coucherai avec un
mec comme vous n un peu trop vieux
peut-être ah
non c'est dur c'est dur hein ça en même
temps e Michel tu es de quelle année toi
je suis 49 moi ah oui pas loin quand on
cherche on trouve mais enfin franchement
je peux pas
c bien est-ce que vous êtes porno vous
regardez des cassettes porno j'ai fait
un truc mieux que ça ah ouais c'est un
scoop j'ai doublé un film porno oh la
vache ah bon ouais c'est pas parce ce
que j'avais besoin d'argent c'est
clapich qui a réalisé un un courtmétrage
porno et j'ai fait une des actrices
c'est gauche je me souviens plus du Tex
mais ça ça me dérange pas le texte
nonange ça ah non je peux dire tout ce
que vous voulez ça ça dérange pas vous
dans l'oralité c'est le pour vous le la
perversion passe par l'oralité vous vous
aimez dire des mots un peu Coch c'est
j'aime ça me dérange pas du tout j'ai
pas de problème avec ça ouais c'est
dommage que je sois trop vieux pour vous
vous m appris des trucs voilà mortel
transfert de Jean-Jacques benex avec
Hélène deeroll Jean gangl Robert civier
et Denis
podalides vous avezormir et maintenant
mesdames messieurs voici le blind test
avec Monsieur Philippe
cor
mais qu'est-ce que c'est
PhIP que
c'ester faire on va déjà faire un
exemple pour bien que tout le monde
comprend Didier s'il vous
plaît
pour vous pour vous c'est Carlos pour
voussard
la
c'est possible ça
so venez venez monsieur parce que
personne ne
trouve il sont trichur avec sux
noisettes
nousormir m rien souff du oui
Stéphan bravo bravo je vi de dire ça va
richichur il répète derrière moi
maintenant si vous dites le nom en
français on le donne un point il répète
bah donne-moi le titre attends attends
Hermine donnez-moi le titre de la
chanson ah ben je sais plus moi voilà
c'est c'est bien allons-y on continue
chanson numéro 3 mime pas alors ça
vaend attendsends merde mer mer mer les
garçons surveille qui
pas sur la place
c'est
lon bon Serge petit replay petit REP je
suis désolé je
suis c'est
Lyon c'est louoyon s'il vous plaît bravo
pour le
[Applaudissements]
moment pour le moment on a un point pour
eux un point pour les
poissons parce que n'oublions pas quand
même que le ce côté supporte ce
côté meilleur tout va bien donc il r un
peu c'est normal ENF il souffle sur
chanson numéro 4 souffle s'en F on a les
top al brun
roug
que se passe je demand un ralenti tu
demande un replay petit replay ser c'est
très Bagaré ce soir a décidé de nous
emmerder
sur il a
raison
rou en même temps c'est Serge ginbourg
heureusement qu'elle le reconna quand
même
je quand même je on VI je peux mais il a
encore quelques chansons pour jouer si
vous voulez montrer à quel point vous
êtes bon chanson numéro
[Musique]
5 merde mer merde
pas
c'est super
connu je va pas insister mais ça fait TR
pour
quand pas nonou ne vous enfonz pas non
c'est pas Yellow Submarine c'est Octopus
gardenàles qu
même gâchez pas votre victoire pour
facile la
beles la VO c'est la même que dans
yellowm êes très bon d' alors on
continue qui chante c'est pour vous
ça quand même pour
vous je et l mon a dit Jul bien entend j
bravo
est au score de France portug alors on
en est au score de France Portugal comme
Philippe me le signale
effectivement 4 ici et zéro de l'autre
côté comment ça vaach ça va
piè je vous donne des réponses question
c'est quoi la question là où après on
remet toutancis super BCO super
B après il y a le je duomar enc ouais
alors allons-y
Didier Joh ouais bravo
Stéphan
[Applaudissements]
Rousseau bien bien bien ils ont des
joueurs hors Communauté européenne ouis
c'est vrai c'est vrai e sans déconna
c'est pas bien vous AZ fini là avec
votre bocal
là c'est nul c'est
[Applaudissements]
nul on l'appelle le
dauphin dans son royaume
aquatique
c'est mich ah
oui PLA je suis d'accord Hermine Hermine
je suis d'accord ce point ne compte
pas ce drôle de B c'est le daupin c'est
Michel Le souff tu sais pourquoi parce
que souffler n'est pas joué oui d'accord
non non ça ne compte pas non mais
j'averti le public vous ne pouvez pas
souffler parce que les points son
systématiquement annulé voilà là il là
il a je exactement oui pas moi je
vérifie parce qu'elle va
perdre pasre de partout il faut juste
qu'
respand vous avoir mis derrière c'est
pas sympa
que Didier
j'ai Mme c'est déjà trop
bravo bravo
é
désoléard est là pour analyser la
défaite pas pour
jou continue 10
[Musique]
j'ai
il y a un
suspensenorme ils ont crié
d'AB je demande en régie on me dit c'est
Nadia on me dit c'est Nadia
bra la bouteille la
bouteille je vous demande de vous
arrêter je vous demande de vous arrêter
tout le monde de vous
arrêter arrêtez-vous je fais évacuer la
salle tu peux rien son les suppors ce
sont les supporteurs absolument on
continue vous allez faire moins les
Mariol la
voix plus
viux
attention attention attention nous
sommes à deux pour ce côté-là pour
l'équipe des petites bouteilles et à 6
pour l'équipe des poissons mais
maintenant il y a le super banco voilà
et effectivement celui qui remporte le
super banco remporte tout celui qui
souffre fait perdre son équipe ah oui
celui qui souffre fait perdre l'équipe
oui voà c'est sûr a
soufflage soufflage il a poissons on
gagné il y a per
d'â vous êtes prêt c'est très très très
compliqué Yanni beaucoup plus compliqué
que votre truc de basket c'est quelqu'un
qui chante
[Musique]
voilàon on a le temps on a le
temps
un jour tu as
décidé de m'mener dans une maison cachée
tu es déjà all en prison une
foisom auord
deette sal sal très très
B mais tu m'as dit que mes yeux brillai
juste comme de pierre
oubl j'avais
écriton
surz arrête vous allez chacun consulter
vos supporteurs
voilà quelqu'un va consulter les
supporteurs et vous revenez puis
j'espère avec la bonne réponse parce que
là je n'accepterai qu'une réponse par
É bravo NAD
voil
cadeau
cadeau pas c'est incroyable quand
[Applaudissements]
même tu m' demandé très gentiment
d'analyser ce qui allait se passer donc
je tiens à dire à nos amis de l'équipe
adverse nous avons appliqué un vieux
principe maoïste l'ennemi avance nous
reculons l'ennemi s'arrête nous nous
arrêtons l'ennemi recule nous
avançons allez voir le docteur vous
aussi allez voir le docteur Gérard
Miller il vous expliquera la
stratégie je suis
désoléésout nul
c'est B dessiner March très fort les
émissions auquelles il participent
marche très fort voici Philippe
gu c'est vraiment le MI le miel et les
abeilles on a commencé comme dans métier
tous les deux bien sûr my friends me you
that the most beautiful in
world je me souviens de ça
philippeuc alors vous participez
Philippe Delluc à une émission qui
s'appelle on a tout essayer sur la même
chaîne un mardi sur de sur France 2 mais
comme vous venez qu'une émission sur de
finalement ça vous fait qu'une fois par
mois en même temps mais bon ouais hein
parce que vous alternez avec Gard Miller
dans l'émission C'est c'est qui le
producteur un peu R qui ne m'engage
qu'une fois par mois
Catherine
barm bien alors l'émission en carton on
peut le dire on a tout essayé d'aurs la
dernière émission le mardi dernier
c'était vraiment avec de Chavanes
vraiment pareil les chiffres étaient les
mêmes j'ai demandé le décompte manuel
parce que j'avais l'impression que
c'était j'avais l'impression c'était
bouché
d'or alors vous
participez participer également et et
nous remercions ici si tu nous regardes
Michel RER de de nous avoir gentiment
prêté une fois par mois Philippe guelluc
et Gérard Miller ça s'appelle Vivement
Dimanche prochain ouais et ça c'est un
dimanche sur un voilà ça c'est quand
même la différence oui alors quand
Michel Drucker vous a recruté il s'est
dit bon Miller il va faire le PSID de
service masure il va faire le
journaliste qui fait sa revue de presse
et puis quand il est tombé sur vous il
vous a dit toi tu vas faire bah écoute
faut que tu trouves ton rôle ou c'est
génial ça vous a donné une liberté
totale oui et en même temps une une
angoisse parce que ces mots précis ont
été et toi tu vas faire tris petits
pointsich et après ça dém de toi il vous
aime beaucoup Michel moi jeaime beaucoup
aussi Michel si tu nous regardes bien
alors oui bien sûr tout était tout était
tout était tout était inventé ouais
partir de comme disait pierre dag partir
de rien pour arriver à pas grandchose le
chemin n'a pas été long al le problème
c'est masure quand drucer lui a dit je
vais prendre guuc il a compris
guilux évidemment il comprenait pas
pourquoi bon fait beaucoup de télé hein
euh et pourtant vous étiez très
circonspect par rapport à la télévision
vous avez dit une vache qui passe à la
télé c'est une vraie star mais c'est
quand même qu'une vache quoi mais oui
enfin que que j'essaie de de de
préciser quand on pense à tous ces
créateurs à tous ces ses peintres ces
scientifiques ces écrivains qui
travaillent parfois sur des œuvres
monumental et qui ne passe jamais à la
télé et qui reste des inconnus à vie
c'est un petit peu pénible de se dire à
côté de ça il y a un crétin qui présente
la météo qui écrit un bouquin qui fait
un tabac en librairie il est
marrant on est en train de te monter une
baraque là
énorme Naomi vous le trouvez comment il
est
bien oui formable éta très bon et voilà
on a commencé
ensemble il avait beaucoup plus de
vêtement à à changer pour se changer que
nous avions et oui elle fait ça parce
que vous savez moi quand sur mon truc il
y a encore un il y a encore un soupul il
a des
poids alors en Belgique vous avvez une
émission qui marchait très bien qui
s'appelait Lollipop et vous l'avez
arrêté pour des raisons artistiques
alors qu'à l'époque vous aviez seulement
le chat qui vous rapportait 20000 balles
par mois donc c'est vrai que vous avez
toujours été 20000 francs belges
c'est-à-dire 3000 franc français ah oui
ah oui oui ah oui ah oui c'est rien
pourant le lip hop en Belgique c'était
culte he ou c'est une émission céit si
vou Monon ouis pour enfant on a déliré
pendant 5 ans en direct alors est-ce que
vous savez ce que ça veut dire guuc en
flamand on l'a su on l'a su guuk guuk
guuc
guuc guuc GC GC je cherche un Luc un Luc
heureux Luc heureux GUC personne sait lu
vous êtes nul vous êtes nul en flamand
ou quoi là on a fait qu'on a fait que 2
ans ça veut dire bonheur bien sûr ah
guuc bah oui guuc alors votre père était
caricaturiste ce qui fait que vous avez
découvert l'humour assez jeune
évidemment puisqueà la maison on en
parlait beaucoup vous avez découvert
akakiri assez assez jeune et puis votre
père est devenu distributeur de films de
pays de l'Est ce qui veut dire que ce
garçon euh avant même de voir des films
de Walt Disney danser déjà en compagnie
de roman Polonski de Miloche formanan de
c'est fou vous avezkovski ou oui je veux
pas dire que je les ai fait sauter sur
mes genoux non mais c'était le contraire
oui oui voilà ouais c'est étonnant pour
un enfant je n'ai jamais vu de ma de mon
de ma vie d'enfant un Walt Disney ouais
parce que c'était mal vu à la maisonou
ou les film venaient de l'Est qui
venaient de l'Ouest c'était un peu comme
ça ouais il était bien é était bolchaud
votre père non non disons NON bien à
gauche bien à gauche oui alors vous
vendez votre premier dessin à l'âge de
15 ans vous êtes très vous étiez très
très précoce à une revie pharmaceutique
vous en souvenez du premierers dessins
que vous avez vendu oui c'était un un
type qui n'avait qu'un c'était très
cruel c'était un type qui n'avait qu'un
bras et qui pêchait et puis il pêche un
autre
[Rires]
bras ah ouais mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
que les les les les Belges sont beaucoup
plus sensibles que les Français au
nonsense à l'humour anglo-saxon hein oui
parce que depuis toujours on est une
sorte de minorité opprimée au sein de
l'Europe on on parle français dans une
partie du du pays on parle flamand dans
une autre partie on sait pas très bien
on est un peu les bâtards de l'Europe et
on était traversé par toutes les
cultures par les Anglais par les
Allemands mais comme certains autres
voilà l'humour allemand a laissé peu de
trac dans le pays finalement mais mais
l'humour anglais l'humour espagnol voilà
tout ça ça a laisser des des traces mais
vous dites que s'il y a tout ce côté
surréaliste en Belgique finalement c'est
parce que c'est pour se délivrer de
l'horreur ambiante d'une certaine façon
oui et puis c'est un moyen de défense
pour les minorités en général pourquoi
l'humour juif est-il si formidable parce
que les Juifs ont toujours dû se battre
se défendre pour vivre l'humour tchck
c'est c'est pareil vous avez un chien
ouais qui s'appelle kilim ce qui veut
dire tapis quand on demande à Philippe
guuc pourquoi il a appelé son chien
kilim il dit parce qu'on veut qu'il
serve plus
[Rires]
tard on va parler du chat comment on
fait vous savez changer les amples ah un
peu mon ve allez-y alors faites voir
naomiil
PLA le chat est content chez
Casterman sa ça très très bien alors
vousz trouvé ça un
soir comme ça vous dessiné vous trouvé
ça c'est venu comment cette histoire de
chatpp rou de la bande dessinée oui je
ne demandais rien à personne et un jour
le journal Le Soir le grand quotidien en
Belgique m'a fait une commande il m'a
dit est-ce que tu pourrais pas nous
inventer un un personnage pour nos pages
du du mardi et puis j'ai voilà je me
suis mis devant une une feuille de
papier et le chat est
apparuent fou ouais et vous avez senti
tout de suite vous aviez trouvé quelque
chose très vite très vite quand j'ai vu
la simplicité du personnage quand j'ai
vu euh vers quoi il allait pouvoir
m'emmener je me suis dit j'ai découvert
quelque chose avec lequel je vais faire
un sacré bout de chemin alors j'ai noté
quelques quelques extrait de du chat euh
si on mettait du mercurochrome dans les
bombes ça soignerait déjà les premiers
blessés ce n'est pas de très bon goût je
sais mais la guerre c'est pas de très
bon goût non
plus les imbéciles prétendent que tous
les noirs se ressemble je connais un
noir qui trouve lui que tous les
imbéciles se ressemblent quand je sors
dans le monde il m'arrive de dire aux
gens j'ai une grande vessie c'est pour
me donner une
contenance hier on m'avait dit que
l'avenir ce serait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on me dit que l'avenir c'est
pour demain quand ça sera ton de
remettre le futur à plus tard c'est
vachement
bien on est des grands fans de de ah non
mais c'est fou quand on voit tous ces
top modèles excusez-moi quand on voit
tous ces top modèles anorexique et quand
on sait ce qu'on les paye on se dit que
ça fait cher le
kilo
F moi ça va il y a aucun problème il y a
des grosses couilles votre
chat non mais c'est vrai hein c'est
c'estes vraies couilles ou c'est gonflé
au silicone non non non non c'est tout
est d'origine les pièces sont d'origine
bravo hein alors ça marche très très
bien ça fait 700 vous en êtes à 750000
exemplaires non ah non vous plaisantez
ah bon ah non 2 millions et demi oui on
est en route vers les 3 millions en
France il est richeliire
ah ou c'est énorme ah ouais vous êtes
rich
alors milliardaire non en Fran belge en
Fran belge non bien vous savez qu'on ne
bouge pas le jingle on vous l' dit ça on
va pas bougerou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pasle
non non vous pouvez venir quand vous
voulez parce que vous ne bougez pas
pendant le jingles j'étais en train de
regarder ses yeux ah oui ça avec Naomi
il faut le savoir quand elle rencontre
un homme pour la première fois il faut
la regarder dans les yeux sinon c'est
même pas la peine de la regarder attende
mais nous on se connaissait depuis
longtemps ouais j'ai regardé ses pieds
moi quel con qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des qu'est-ce
que alors Philippe guelluc vous
connaissez le portrait chinois oui le
portrait chinois c'est si tu étais une
fleur quelle fleur serais-tu bon
l'antiortrait chinois c'est plus
compliqué si vous étiez une
injure ce serait gros con ah ouais parce
que gros con c'est vraiment bien parce
que pour être un gros con il faut pas
être gros ou il suffit d'être con c'est
vrai ça a l'avantage de vous permettre
d'ê Belinda vous suivez là oh tout à
fait oh là là très bien comment on dit
gros con en anglais alors et ben on se
posait la question précisément mais euh
on s'est dit euh B
ouais of shit c'est beau ça ah non non
non non si vous étiez une
maladie la maladie de Parkinson parce
que ça me permettrait de continuer à
jouer des maracasses PZ plus dessiner
pour le
coup si vous étiez un accident en art on
parle d'accident heureux h un peintre
dont le pinceau dérap crée parfois une
tâche magnifique ouais si vous étiez une
perversion je crois que je suis une
perversion une guerre un un conflit
nucléaire mondial h ça résoudrait pas
mal de problèmes oui c'est sûr le
réchauffement de la terre ça serait
régleré au moins si vous étiez un
visce le visce sans fin inventé par
Michelange une
trahison ah vous savez je suis quelqu'un
de de fidèle en amitié dans le travail
et dans la vie ce serait peut-être de
vous révéler des secrets touchant Michel
Drucker ah oui Michel Drucker et son
chien oui parce que je les vois parfois
dans le
bureau et je sais qui prend les
véritables
décisions si vous étiez si vous étiez
une
arme un canon j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
un canon vous en avez en face de vous
ben oui
merci
in France en France quand une fille est
très jolie on dit c'est un canon voilà
un
canoninda ok merci oui bien sûr toujours
là une cicatrice si vous étiez une
cicatrice le sourire c'est une cicatrice
qui ne se referme jamais oh là là oh là
là mais attends arrête ça va c'est bon
arrête ça y est arrête c'est bon mais oh
ah oui mais il est trop fort si vous
étiez un salot
vous
ah
oua c'est rare que j coupe à ça si vous
y étiez un dictateur vous pouvez pas
dire vous là vous l' déjà dit une
fois le maître du monde ouais oui parce
que je fais pas les choses en à moitié
donc maître du monde ou rien maître du
monde ou rien si vous étiez une
infirmité La Celle VI oui parce que ça
va ça va c'est une infirmité qui a des
avantages tout de même c'est pas
douloureux oui c'est vrai ça fait gagner
du temps le matin pour se coiffer et
puis ça rend tellement séduisant oui
c'est vrai vous en tous les cas ça vous
va vachement bien ça va pas c'est ça
[Rires]
pas un homme chauve ça vous ça vous fait
fuir non ça me fait
rire grandère est complètement Chau et
ben voilà fa penser à son
grandère
[Musique]
l'oire est
réglé
grandère mariage il ne va pas donc à
l'église parce qu'il veut pas enlever
son chapeau et quand j'avais 4 ans à
l'aéroport il a je lu enlev son chapeau
il était fux après
moi si vous étiez un microbe la grippe
ouais vous vous tombez vous êtes microbe
et vous allez vous avez la possibilité
de donner la grippe je sais pas au
chanteur Carlos ou à Naomi Campell vous
hésitez pas ah oui c'est clair vous
choisissez Carlos bien
sûr si vous étiez un
assassin un regard HM si vous étiez un
terroriste Carlos ah
c'est
si vous étiez une torture une torture
oui une torture
ninja oui une conneries comme ça j' ah
non il est il est con il est con il sait
bien excuse-moi j'allais dire Zoé la
torture oh merde tu vois commoi rapide
si vous étiez une
humiliation une humiliation ninja non ça
marche pas ça marche
pas rester comme un con à pas arrivver à
sortir bonne réponse en même temps et si
vous étiez une mort la petite mort ah
bonne
répseour bravo
formable merci beaucoup merci d'êre venu
on va vous faire un
tri merci beaucoup au
revoir et maintenant j'accueille 700
millions de Chinois et moi et moi et
[Musique]
moi
bonsoir bonsoir j'ai appris TR qu mots
comme
ça vous êtes aussi vous êtes très
beau ou avez des
gâteaux je sais pas
TR vous appz comment je m'appelle l
dévezvous
physiquement aussi B que très bien
quelle est la raison de votre
appel on
t'écoutee Brab
cétaitb trce pour les
américainesinda une
copineinda regarde comment on applaud ah
c'est comme ça qu'onit voirit
voirise je raconter l'hoire on a
récemment vu arriver en France France
les romancières chinoises voilà on
connaissait pas romanères chinois donc
il y a Mian Mian qui a écrit les bonbons
chinois et il y a way qui a écrit
Shangai baby voilà alors on est loin de
de
l'épouse soumise au pied bandé et même
de la révolutionnaire en costume Mao
d'ailleurs dans les années 50 je savais
pas du temps du maoisme Triomphant les
chinoises avaient droit seulement à une
demheure de sex par semaine avec
Monsieur cela suffisait par exemple cela
suffisait pour mes parents et et voilà
pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui voilà
parce que ça lui suffit pas Shangai ça
ressemble un peu Hong Kong non
maintenant étrangement
non ou je pense que
c'est on peut la considérer comme une
sœur de Hong Kong et d'ailleurs pendant
les années 30 c'était une pale de de
l'Orient et Shangai a été comparé à
Paris ah des petites femmes exagér ouis
de Shangai bien sûr maisaintenant il y a
des grands magasins des McDo des cyber
café donc faut le savoir c'est dire
c'est pas du tout comme comme on imagine
c'est une espèce de mégapo donc on peut
y aller maintenant on peut vraiment y
aller on y a vu des voitures on a vu des
voitures non puis vie nocturne terrible
he il y a des il y a beaucoup de musique
de drogue et de la techno he
Shangai et alors les romancières
chinoises ont cristallisé un petit peu
cette cette révolution alors votre
bouquin Shangai baby là voilà je le
montre à la caméra vous savez comment on
fait
way
elle le fait bien le fait bienit la
Chinoise alors ça sort sous trois
couvertures donc j'en montre plein
encore voilà j'en montre une autre comme
ça et j'en montre encore une autre voilà
allez trois couvertures ouais alors B
c'est un bouquin qui s'est vendu quand
même en Chine à 500000 exemplaires et
qui a été pilonné parce que ça fait un
scandale là-bas pourquoi trois
couvertures parce qu'elle aur plus chaud
bon allez on y va on y va on y va
excuse-moi d'avoir coupé pour ça je suis
désolé d'avoir coupé pour ça Didier
pardon pardon pardon Didier interview
[Applaudissements]
vérité bien alors donc on va parler de
vous maintenant très sérieusement après
ce préambule sur la Chine et les
romanères Chinoises vous avez 28 ans
vous êtes issu d'un milieu aisé fille de
professeur d'université et vous-même
vous êtes diplômé de littérature la
prestigieuse univers C de foudan à
shangï alors le premier scandale que
vous avez fait en Chine c'est quand vous
sorti votre premier bouquin qui
s'appelait l'écrit perçant du
papillon vous aviez fait un happening où
vous exposiez se slip blanc où il y
avait une nouvelle écrite sur les slips
et votre photo comme signature c'est
vrai c'est ça oui oui oui oui oui tout à
fait ou ça fait un scandale là B ça
non euh
oui on peut le dire comme ça parce que B
euh depuis ce moment-là les hommes
chinois euh ont peur de moi tandis que
les femmes chinoises je pense qu'elles
sont contentes de ce que j'ai dit parce
que je sers en quelque sorte à leur
porte-parole voilà une sorte de Virginie
des pandes chinoise voyez ce que je veux
dire très bien moi j'essaie de pas lire
les sous-titres en même
temps bien alors ce bouquin là shangaiil
baby donc c'est l'histoire de Coco parce
qu'ils prennent des noms comme ça c'est
mode de prendre des noms coco comme Coco
Chanel elle a une copine qui s'appelle
Madonna donc voilà c'est c'est mode
là-bas voilà ah la chanteuse ouais bien
bien juste donc coco à 25 ans elle vit à
shanghï et elle partage sa vie entre
Tian Tian qui est un jeune chinois euh
qui est impuissant faut dire le il est
oui il est il est junky donc quand on
est junky de toute façon on est
impuissant même si on n'est pas
impuissant donc ça c'est Tian Tian qui
l'aime beaucoup qu' l'idolâtre et puis
Marc qui est un Allemand et qui a un
énorme sexe ah oui sexe de 2 M
pas de M mais avec qui elle baise assez
frénétiquement coco l'héroïne c'est
autobiographique c'est plutôt une espèce
de
semiographie autobiographie
bibliographie c'est pas si
grand bien donc effectivement le livre a
été censuré ça fait scandale
parceffectiv sont souvent ça arrive les
chinois sont pas satisfait et avec les
étrangers ell connaissent un plaisir
peut-être un petit peu supérieur ENF
tout le monde le sait vous dites
vous-même tout le monde le sait là-bas
il faut pas le dire encore moins
l'écrire voilà donc a un peu mis les
pieds dans le
plat parce que d'après les traditions
chinoises on peut faire certaines choses
mais on ne peut pas en
parler je pense que ça fait partie de
nos tradition orientale voilà donc se
taper des Allemands avec un sexe énorme
c'est possible mais il faut pas le dire
écrire voilà chez nous c'est le
contraire alors page 323 euh alors cette
allemand l'a fait fantasmer parce
qu'elle voit alors que le mec il est
marié avec une écolo qui s'occupe de la
protection de l'environnement il a rien
d' aile l'allemand hein mais elle
fantasme quand même sur le côté un peu
page 323 les femmes aiment avoir dans
leur lit des fascistes dont les bottes
de cuir raisonnent à leur oreille ça ça
fait un peu trip cuir tuis c'est un peu
un peu sm un peu sm [__] cuir
non ou je pense que il faudrait
pas ma comprendre ce que
j'aelisist parce que bon je pense que
pour les
femm ell ont le propres fantasme
certaines désirent même faire l'amour
avec leur père déjà page 80 ça commence
j'imagine les yeux germaniques bleu
cruelle et féroce vous excite
pasuraitil é en costume nazi avec des
bottes un un manteau de cuir ah non ah
oui c'est c'est un mais ça va cartonner
en Allemagne
son ça peut cartonner oui ils ont pas eu
la même chose que nous avec eux voilà
exactement c'estàd qu'ils ont pas vécu
la même chose que nous dans les années
40 donc pour eux c'est un peu plus loin
rest folklore ouais voilà alors cette
allemand donc comme je l'ai dit un
organe impressionnant et alors elle
l'héroïne coco ça ça l'a fait crier de
douleur oui tout à fait
c'est pour ça que en fait coco se trouve
dans une situation délicate
entre le désir et la
souffrance alors que toutes les femmes
cherchent à les combiner ensemble
exactement donc elle elle continue
malgré la taille du sexe et et la phrase
c'est j'ouvre les yeux avec un mélange
de haine et d'amour dans le regard ass
c'est chaud hein très très chaud du mal
à ça marché sur
toi truc qui marche
Suri non il y a des scènes Terri un
moment téléphone enfin pas vous mais
l'héroïne cocou elle téléphone à Ti Tian
donc le pauvre qui est Jung donc il est
impuissant évidemment et pendant ce
temps Marc lèche son sexe à travers sa
petite culotte ah ben voilà on y
arrive jusqu je qu'est-ce qu'il
a c'est bien la littérature chinoise
d'aujourd'hui mais là ça y est ou on est
dedans
là je voudrais savoir si les hommes
français ça le arrive de lécher leurs
femmes ah moi j'ai jamais fait l'amour
personnellement donc ça c'est des trucs
j'espère un jour y arriv à ça mais non
ça on a jamais fait ça il va à travers
la culotte c'est vrai que bon c'est il
va falloir nous filer le Bouin non mais
attends c'est pour ça qu' y en a trois
exemplaires en même temps bien bon enfin
à la fin page 306 j'en resterai là parce
que sinon après ça là la tension monte
ou je sais c'est pour ça Marc part Marc
part
ou comment vous savez ça bah parce que
ça peut pas durer une histoire imp il
MEAH évidemment lui aussi le pauvre de
chagrin comme si j'étais pas làou bien s
on a déjà fait des émissions emble
déjà quoi quoi c'est pas
moi bien alors les réactions les
réactions en Chine le livre pilonnet
donc détruit complètement détruit et
puis alors poursuivi vous avez été
poursuivi par des fous qui voulait
absolument venger l'affront fait à
l'honneur national parce que bien
évident
les Chinois lire ça pas làbas alors là
elle est obligé de
rester la
chineig restez en franceez en
France je n'ai pas l'intention de rester
en France ENF plutôt je ne sais pas
encore mais j'ai entendu dire que il y a
aussi un
écrivain francochinois qui s'appelle qui
est un grand écrivain
prix il a eu prix Nobel bien
sûr ou tout à fa et d'ailleurs j'ai
obtenu il m'a off un livre et moi j'ai
fait
pareementonn il habite dans une tour en
banlieu là ça va lui faire faire vre Bou
ça changer les
idées
voici
et ouis alors voilà vite mon ver est
vide c'est le problème problème de ver
vide hop tout de suite une vanne ver
vide qui qui cons sent bien alors dans
la nouvelle nouvelle nouvelle nouvelle
formule de nul par ailleursilleur vous
intervenez au visiophone ouais hein
c'est ça ça bon ben voilà bon on va
regarder ce que vous faites regarder ce
que vous faites
Serge bonsoir NAD kit bon gosse en
activité moi je voulais parler d'Ariel
dombal et BHL parce que j'ai lu dans un
journal qui se vous voit enfin encore
c'est pas ça le pire le pire c'est qu'il
couche
ensemble bonsoir Alibaba j'appelle avec
un des voleurs parce qu'ton Joh il a dit
qu'il voulait être réincarné en femme
bah il a bien raison en plus il a déjà
toute la garde robobe bonsoir Alan
quaterman moi je voulais parler des
sondages de la presse là comme quoi il y
a de moins en moins de curé en France
enfin en même temps c'est bien c'est
surtout les enfants qui vont être
contents hein bonsoir chapis chapeau ài
du matin moi je vous appelle parce que
carambé et sa femme ils vont divorcer
mais attendez c'est normal il lui a
menti tout le temps il a dit qu'il joue
au Real de Madrid elle l'a jamais vu
jouer c'est pour ça il a Moti bonsoir
prosperère je suis le roi du pain
d'épices moi j'appelle à propos de la
disparition de garciimort franchement ça
sert à rien d'être triste hein pour une
fois qui a réussi un tour bonsoir Maria
et carré nous on vous appelle parce
qu'on a lu dans le journal que Céline di
elle va s'acheter une maison au Canada
elle avait déjà l'accent maintenant elle
a la maison bah faut y aller maintenant
Céline allez r cheztoi tuas
entendu bonsoir Manix détective privé
moi je voulais réagir parce que j'ai vu
que il y a des rumeurs sur Pascal Obispo
qui serait avec Fabien
bartez personnellement je sais pas si
c'est vrai mais enfin en tout cas la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il pourront
jamais faire de gosse bonsoir Simbad
marin j'appelle là parce qu'ils vont
faire une poupée Jennifer Lopez j'espère
qu'ils vont pas lui faire le même m cul
à la poupée hein par sinon c'est les
mecs qui vont jouer avec quoi bonsoir St
et Charden nous on voulez réagir sur
Christian Clavier là parce qu'on a lu
qu'il allait jouer Napoléon taille dein
ego surdimensionné tout correspond hein
ok
Christian c'est vachement bien hein oui
parce merci non non vraiment fait
plaisirarte cousin vous vous êtes donc
tous les soirs dans nul par ailleurs nul
par ailleur oui Canal Plus et alors vous
êtes aussi dans le grand zapping
d'Emmanuel gum voilà oui c'est ex fr
Omar vous savez comment on fait donc
tous les samedi à 19h25 jusqu'à 20h45
Fred et Homar avec Emmanuel Gaume dans
plus de
zapping bien bien bien
bienouis toute une banane on va parler
d'accessoire qui avit pas d'accessoire
dans C'est quoi l'émission C'est vous
êtes ça rien c'est comment c'est comment
l'ambiance à Canal alors l'ambiance à
Canal qu'est-ce que c'est canal c'est
génial canal c'est une chaîne de
télévision l'esprit canal la grande
famille la grande famille de canal c'est
sympa ouais ah leonde s'entend bien et
on mange pas de porc pourquoi parce que
tout le monde est musulman ça personne
le
sait qui le sait voilà aucun doigt se
lève on mange pas de porc à Canal
alors Fred 26 ans Fred c'est incroyable
parce que j'ai même pas dit mon âge
quand je suis arrivé en log il y a de
l'info làdans l' 26 ans mais à la Colle
sur
Loup il sait tout sur toi franchement ça
Duck de droit
ouais j'ai arrêté en licence non mais
écoute-moi bien Christophe parce que
Christophe je le connais c'est mon
voisin he Christophe qui est décédé en
plus hier alors qu'il est là à
l'émission C'est incroyable non mais
c'est ce que truc moi je suis un peu
tendu parce que là vous avez parlé de
son doc de droit et moi j'ai pas mon bac
alors faut pas le dire attention va le
savoir dans la fiche précédente attendez
attendeiche l'affiche non dug de droit
famille bourgeoise c'est vrai quand même
que vous avez refusé il y a pas de
bourgeoisie hein par contre c'est très
très grave moi j'en ai rien à [__] je
pourrais être plein de Tune et cetera et
cetera et vogue la galère faut pas que
tu me filmes toi aussi hein je dit tout
à l'heure tu prévenu avant e faut pas me
filmer toi parce que je t'aime pas donc
vous venez à Paris vous venez à Paris
vous quittez la Colle sur Loup vous
venez à Paris c'est marant vous faites
un stage non mais c'est comme si vous
parceon regarde la télé et on se dit
[__] comment il trouve je me dis
autant Bernard Bernard ça fait 30 ans de
carrière et ca tout le monde le connaît
donc c'est normal qu'on est des infos
parce qu'il a dit des conneries il a pas
dit des conneries et C Bernard on a du
doc ouais moi moi quoi moi vous arrivez
à Paris faites un stage à fun vous
rencontrez Éric et RAM ah et voilàvie de
d'allumer une banane parce que c'est le
le Nouvel An Nouvel An australien a de
la banane Omar Omar 23 ans ouais né à 23
ans attention 23 ans aujourd'hui ouais
com ça 20 tu vois ce que je veux
direen est pas sorti
là là tu vois Lau là to tu s public
surchauffé mais bon public bon pote de
Jamel et d'anecta c'est vrai ça ouais
d'anecta c'est un comptable pote de
Jamel et d' bon non parce que faut
préciser non c'est vrai que j'ai de pot
avec c'est eux qui vous ont aidé c'est
Jamel aidé ils m'ont il m'ont don non
non non c'est il vous ont donné
l'adresse de canal déjà c'est pas mal
non il m'a pas donné l'adresse carment
il m'a pas juste donné l'adresse il m'a
accompagné il m'a tiré par la main parle
en même temps ou tout le monde en parle
tout le monde en parle monde parle que
tout le monde peut en parler aussi oui
ou c'est vrai parce que moi mon voisin
qui a 87 ans tu dis tout le monde en
parle il dit tu as dit parce que tout le
monde en parle al parle pas moi bien là
je vais mettre un jingle parce que c'est
la fin de la première partie de
l'interview ça
va et là je vous dis vous savez qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle ah oui mais
ah non non on rallume on rallume alors
voilà alors là ça fait 40 ans que je
fais de la télé ça te fait marrer parce
cette personne rigole pour tout aussi
c'est l'avantage quand que ça a commencé
ça commencé quand
même voilà en 74 ch pétrolier je P que
personne n au courant
euh voilà tu as fini de rire ça fait
plaisir non non ce que je veux dire
pourquoi ne pas bouger pendant le jingle
tu me dis ça à moi non mais je sais ça
fait des semaines que je B cont inall
pas le jingleas raison Vy non mais gen
rajoute et je surjoue pourquoi pourquoi
surjouer pourquoi et cetera parce que
parce que voilà pourquoi pourquoi parce
que imaginons que par exemple ravayac
oui non parce que j'ai travaillé avec
avec une meuf qui s'appelle Sophie dans
les loges elle me dit ouais ravac et ce
qui a tué le roi imaginons que ravak
soit il soit pas mort et qu' viennent et
que vous mour vous mourriez mourrez et
tu en as touché de la bonne là ah voilà
très
marrant la drogue on ne bouge pas
pend on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle ne
bouge pas pendant le jinglele voilà non
mais je sais mais j'avais pas fini ma
phrase c'est ça le problème mais tu peux
la finir maintenant c'est pas un souci
non mais je me disait un problème de
ravayac he ravayac 2000 par exemple s'il
arrivait et qui vous tuait Thierry mais
on serait bien dans la merde qu' on
saura jamais pourquoi on ne bouge pas
avant un jingle Laurent baffille a
essayé pouron Laurent baffi a une
notoriété Laurent baffi a fait si et
deci de là et cetera pourquoi pour qui
et on l'a jamais dit pourqu bouge pas et
voilà on ne saura jamais j'emporterai le
secret dans ma tombe dommage c'est
dommage parce qu'on a qu'une vie bah oui
mais moi personne le saura non en fait
je vous dire la vérité il y a le le le
secret est enfermé dans mon coffre à la
banque dans une enveloppe scellée qu'on
ouvrira à ma mort alors une Chala que tu
meur alors ah non mais c'est vrai je
l'ai marqué une Chala qui Meur tout le
monde lève les bras tout le monde lève
les bras
inchal son MEUR en même temps c'est pour
rigoler hein vous saz que le public nB
qu'à moi vous avez vu tout le monde lève
les
bras voilà merdeis du publicque je te
l'avais pas dit bien dressé j'essie de
faire des vannes criantes aussi voit pas
à la télé des Vanes criant est-ce que
c'est merde et voilà alors qu'en fait je
suis même pas énervé il fait que pour
moi c'est normal je suis même pas énervé
est-ce que c'est vrai que vos parents
sont blancs et que les vôres sont noirs
quoi et ça vous fait rigoler ah oui
c'est l'interview mensonge ah oui faut
dire quand c'est oui faut dire non ah
c'est une interview mensonge dire le
contraire de la vérité oui
ouais et vous ils sont noirs mais c'est
évident d'accord mais c'est ridicule
estil vrai que lorsqualin de GREF vous a
vu pour la première fois il vous a pas
reconnu qui nous a pas reconnu quand il
vous a vu pour la première fois mais
c'est normal enfin c'est pas
normal Ahou non mais je rien compris moi
par contrat vous avez exigé quoi dans
votre contrat avec Canal+ ah nous ce
qu'on a exigé tuux ouais rien non parce
queon s'en occupe pas en fait inter
mensonge rien non mais fais le calcul
fais le
calcul dans votre bureau vous avez quoi
un canal la tectonique des plaques
c'est-à-dire que c'est un problème non
non mais sérieusement non non la faille
de sint Andreas c'est un problème de
géologie c'est intéressant parce que la
tectonique des plaques on en parle pas
assez et ça se frotte comme ça et hop la
faille passe par canal exactement d'ù
les scores les vacances vous les prenez
où mensonge toujours ou pas ah ouais ah
c'estong ah ouais parce que moi je reste
chez moi ouais le calcul n part fais le
calcul
bravo vous avez t à
dormir Didier première ch alors
attention stop vous savez comment
Jean-Marie Colomb au première note vous
devez me dire
l'interprète sera facile pour vous parce
que vous êtes un spécialiste de la
chanson populaire attention TASS prêt
jeunas prêt tout le monde est prêt
attention c'est très sérieux attention
didiera il venait d'avoir 18 ans vous
connaissez pas ça mais quand même
écr PASC c'est vrai écrit par Pascal
absolument deè
chansonierte
pas pas
less
pas stop alors le public stop le public
on a pas tous les jours on a pas tous
les jours 20 ans Michel jeuness pas vous
avez pas trouvé Bert Silva
Silva 20
ans chanson numéro 3 pour le un point
pour ma fille 3 Souchon ou Souchon
bravo
ff 2 chanson numéro
4 bravo
Barbara bravo ça me fait plaisir si vous
aimez les Beatles
[Musique]
déjà
14 ans les
Gaulois
bien
pêche attendez qu' chante troué tout de
suite ànabourg
non
ouais B fille là c'est il connais
tout ça vous plaît
[Musique]
ça del pêche comment tu 15 ans cétait
nos 15 ans
en politique il est nul mais en blindest
il est fort à force de reconnaître que
sur plan politique c'est pas un génie
politique bille mais c'est vrai que là
en blind test il est bon hein sec pas
monde Michel c'est B là vous devez
trouver
ça bravo Michel Jonas qu Mme qu
[Applaudissements]
même little
cheberry attention là c'est plus
[Musique]
dur les parisienn ouais
ou bravo les Parisiennes bien
sûing stop voilà donc j'imagine il a 6
schuls à 1 et jeunas à 1 donc voilà vous
avez explosé alors le super banco celui
qui trouve le super banco peut remporter
le conteste alors évidemment que baffi
fait ça change rien il suffit de trouver
le super banco bien sûr c'est dur le
super banco c'est dur c'est le super
banco tente allez on tente tente le
super banco
attention la ville c'est introuvable ça
ahor c'est la chanson de Massimo
Gardia moi Mo j'aime bien les vieilles
de 83 ans c'est la chanson de MIMO
Gardia
[Musique]
introuvable les fes sont de
monx c'est personne
sa c'est y et les abeilles
3 ans c'est la chanson de
[Musique]
Massim merci on
rallume donc c'est la ma fille la ma
fille bravo cétait tout le monde en
parle l'émission pas comme les autres
rendez-vous dans 8 jours samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Ciao
has space but you can't even find
my there a nothing you can
douse had enough of me baby being part
of you just who
do this to
who do you think you are take
man
[Musique]
MAK
MOV
MOV MOV
MOV move it on up
it move it on
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
abonnez-vous mettez un pouce
B